Dude, dude, dude, dude, they're Dell. No whiskey row. Do you want some? Yeah,
I want a drink. Yeah. Rally. No, Bro, you've got a long day. Okay,
I'll stay drunk. Oh, let's get a little, okay. Pause it.
I'll get it. Okay, Jamie's going gonna get the booze. Look at that.
Jamie leaves the salon to get the booze. Thank you Jamie. Real, real pro.
Get some ice too. Beautiful. So lot of fucking shit going on, man.
Lot of shit going on. How about that Colby Covington Fella. Huh Bro? Dude,
everybody better shut the fuck up now. He's for real. He's for real.
Anybody who didn't think he was for real after that Robbie Lawler fight,
you got to go. Wow. Well the problem is is he talked so much shit,
which I find hilarious and it's you're tuning in to watch him lose,
which is he's doing it right cause to, in all honesty,
we like him cause we're balls deep in UFC and MMA.
But like my brother who's not that big of a fan, it's like this is all he does.
I'm like, I know you, you gotta understand though what he's doing.
This guy is amazing and he's going to do it for five rounds or 25 minutes.
And where's Ya, it's to me, it's fascinating. It is fascinating,
but it's not entertaining for a general fan. Typically.
He's not knocking dudes out. He's not a lot of submissions.
You know what I'm saying? So for the, for the General Fan, like, oh,
this guy talks all this shit,
but he's doing it right because talking all that shit,
like don't only see this guy get fucked up. Even Jon Jones posted,
you let everyone down, you know, like, uh, uh, Robbie Lawler let everybody down.
You know what I'm saying? Cause he wants, everybody wants Colby to lose, right?
Kobe's doing an exact, everyone's playing into his game plan. The idol. Love it.
Well that's how Floyd Mayweather became so rich.
Floyd Mayweather did not become so rich because his fights were so exciting.
His fights in his early career were way more exciting.
He was a savage or then he could go to [inaudible],
but he broke his hands a bunch of times. Correct. And you know,
and also realize like this is not the way to have a long career and walk out of
it with all your brains intact. Well think, remember,
think how good Jon Fitch was. Oh yeah. He was up Monster Chore. Nice guy,
true professional beat. Some of the very best was tough to beat.
Didn't talk shit though. So no one really cared.
So as soon as he had some issues, I remember he was like, Hey,
I don't like the way my face looks in that video game. UFC was like, cool,
your cut. Like what the fuck? I'm 20 and oh man. Yeah,
I think they'd cut them just because of, um,
but either one of those is good. This is all we have in this room.
We have a bunch of that. Um, which the Buffalo Buffalo Trace.
We have buffalo trace in the bag. I don't trust skinny bottles. Yeah,
that seems weird, right? Yeah, it's for girls.
I'll trust skinny girls wear skinny bottles, bro.
Canadian whiskey and Maple Syrup now can't do maple on Quito, Bro.
Straight Quito. When did I say I sent you and Brian a text.
Your boy was up to two 73 dude, you got to two 73
what were you eating? Road. Lot of tough road dog life. Cause when I get into,
and there's all this,
you know if you're in Nashville and Philly where there's great food,
so I was just eating and drinking at night and no one said anything to me.
I hear Ya. No one said anything. No. And then I remember I went to Hawaii,
I went to Hawaii. I was looking at the other dads and like, damn,
these dads aren't shape. I look like shit. My girl is like, no,
you look fine. Everyone's lying man. Now I got on the scale.
It's not fine. Your Boys Been Kito 14 days. I feel grained days, 40 days.
Stress can knock. You had a creek. Quito. Anyway though, this is whiskey.
There's no sugar in whiskey. There's not, nope, it's alcohol,
but there's no sugar in it. But alcohol doesn't convert to cheers. My brother,
his brother. Good to see you, man. Good to see you too.
Alcohol doesn't convert into sugar. I don't think so.
Especially whiskey cause whiskey and vodka are safe on Keto genic diet.
Oh Woo. It's two in the afternoon, Bro. Yeah, two in the afternoon.
Fight Alcoholic now. Hey drink. And I'm like a super shitty rum light.
It's fun to uh, drink a little bit before a show, right? Nothing better man.
Okay, so me take that. Started me on it. Oh my God. You look good up here.
I'm messing around. I get loose. Yeah. I don't want to be tight now.
I want to be tight. No, you don't want to drink your problem either.
But the Colby Covington thing is, um, look what he did.
If, if you, if you want to put it in perspective for a regular person,
Robbie Lawler is one of the biggest fucking savages to ever compete in the
sport. He's an animal. And Colby shot him down. He shut everything down.
He shut his entire game down and he did it with an unprecedented work rate he
made. He was punching one punch every two seconds. Nuts,
which is nuts. I mean that is it for,
to do that over five fucking rounds against one of the greatest welterweights of
all time and Robbie Lawler and when every single fucking round, some 10,
eight rounds, I thought, this isn't even close. Not even close. I mean,
Robbie occasionally would swing and connect and then Colby would immediately hit
him three or four times more and then take him down or clinch with them and beat
him up and it was amazing. Colby strike is not terrible either. It's very good.
Pretty damn good. It's very technical and the volume, the volume is incredible.
Here's my thing, if I'm fighting Colby, like if I'm a Karma Uzman,
if I'm fighting Colby, I'm getting a guy like campaigns.
If I see my opponent running with campaigns,
I'm reaching out to another ultra marathon or figuring it out. Well,
Comoro can't run. That's right. He can't do roadwork. His leads still. Yes.
Oh yeah. It's not getting any better. His knees are mangled,
but if you're doing something right, well his cardio is off the charts too,
but it's just, he does different things.
You can do a lot of different things to work storming and stuff. Sure.
Swimming you can do a lot. Oh yeah. The uh, assault bike.
Um, you know the, um, that echo bike,
that rogue makes that is as good as Jacob ladder thing. Yeah. Yeah.
They need that. [inaudible] and I feel like it's lying to me.
I work out every morning on that thing. I've never been thicker. Yeah.
But you're eating like an animal still. It says I burned a thousand calories.
Probably I call bullshit dude. I don't think so. Manto hippie
full of Shit. Food truck diaries.
You need to stop lying to no food truck tiger thing going hard in those
[inaudible] and I'm the only one eating it. Yeah.
Cause the other day the guest is talking. So tell me how you got started.
Lobster. Fucking sandwiches and shit. Pizza. None stuff.
And he had no shit ready to 70. Yeah.
That's why I can't find at heavyweight right now, man. That's what happens. Oh,
hard. But if I'm a Camarillo, y'all see cardio's not a prom for him,
but man Colby, have you ever seen him tired ever? No. No,
I mean he had that one loss in the UFC,
but that was particularly because he came to the fight injury,
took the fight on short notice, but he's,
he's got an amazing style,
that style of wrestling and striking and as a person who's fascinated by
tactics, right? Yeah. Like his tactics are incredible because he's,
he's got great discipline to never,
he's never bites down his mouthpiece and throws as hard as he can. Never.
Everything is like a calculated, the output is all the same.
It's just constant, constant back, back, back kick, Bang, Bang, Bang, Bang,
Bang, Bang. He doesn't really fire power shots like he's like, oh no,
this is a marathon where you're going to sell. It's all the same pace.
It's all, he's just constantly hitting you constantly moving forward.
Constant volume and it seemed like Robbie was waiting for him to pause in front
of him or get a little tired so he could fire shots off and the bobbing and
weaving that Robbie was doing. Like what was all that about? 20 tired. I mean,
I guess doing all that Bob and weave and I was like damn rough on the Corp.
Yeah man, that's rough on the core. I try bobbing and weaving for a minute.
If you're at home, just try doing this for a minute. Just a minute.
Just a minute. Realtime. And Robbie's just trying to avoid getting beat up.
I mean this punch is just relentless. They never end.
And what's funny too about Colby is love him or hate him is he doubles down
cause he got on the mic and his line about Matt Hughes. Oh my God. Dude. Pete.
I was watching it and I was, where was, I was in Nashville.
I was watching the room with the Derrick posting a son, uh, Ahmad my openers.
And uh, when they said that they were aware of uh, Matt Hughes and go,
that's ridiculous. I'm like, that's fantastic.
It's hey cause it is messed up. But that's his character, man.
He's a heel and he just doubled down so hard, so hard.
Cause Matt Hughes is really close around me long. And he said,
you think what he said for those that have what's fight, he goes,
you would think Robbie Lawler would take a lesson from his boy,
Matt Hughes and get off the train tracks when a train is coming.
He's just all fair in love and war. Yeah. The most controversial,
ruthless shit that he could say. And here's what else do.
So we're impressed by his tactics, right?
You know what's even more impressive as a former fighter,
it's stressful enough fighting another grown man
with a steel cage, especially when they're really good. It's fucking stressful.
Now imagine talking all that Shit and you gotta deal with the consequences.
People hate you and he's a good dude. Yeah. Dr Campaign is,
he's a different guy. Great Guy. Yeah. So he's a normal dude outside,
but he has to deal with all that pressure and still perform.
Then get on the mic. I wonder if he's ever just in bed. It's like,
God damn tell me these death threats are getting real old after that fight.
He has a real shot at being a world champion. A real shot.
I know he was already the interim world champion.
Those don't count after that fight. They don't count. No. And well,
you know how, you know they don't count.
They stripped him and he didn't even lose. Yeah. It doesn't matter.
How does that make no sense? He,
they stripped him because he didn't want to fight again quickly after a five
round fucking war with RDA. Any needed surgery.
But also they don't count either because your contract doesn't, you don't get,
when you're a champ, your contract,
you get bumped up to higher pay interim champs. Don't get bumped up.
What it was. What was the surgery for? Um,
it was something I feel like in his face, like in sinus. Yeah. Something else.
Major. Yeah. Something like a deviated Septum. Yeah. Yeah. Um, yeah.
So he's a fucking f. He's a phenomenal fighter. But now think about this.
You take his style, he doesn't go backwards. Wrestling, cardio,
Kamara Huseman doesn't go backwards. Wrestling. Cardio. Yeah.
The only thing I see.
I would imagine Comoros can be a slight favorite because of his power. Yeah.
One kind of distinguishing kind of factors. Kamar has a lot more power, right?
Camaros. He can knock you out. Neither was a knockout artists, right?
C'Mon can knock people out though. [inaudible]
can knock people out too.
But his approach is to throw everything at like 50 60% he was slaying in some
early in that first round against Robbie. They were exchanging,
if you want to connect, it could have been trolled for either guy or either guy.
He was getting Robert's respect and I think that was the strategy that you ha
you kind of have to wade through the fire with Robbie in the beginning cause
he's coming hard. You know he's coming, coming. He's coming hard.
Now here's the question for you is what's more impressive what Colby did to
Robbie Lawler or what C'mon Huseman did at Tyrone Woodley?
It's a very good question.
Well obviously Tyron Woodley was the champion and Robbie Lawler was several
years removed from the title. So you have to look at it that way. Right.
Tyron took the title from Robbie with a one punch knockout and Robbie's had
some, some losses since then. Some wars. Yeah, some wars since then.
The Ben Asker fight in particular all beat Woodley when he was fucking would,
yes, yes.
But according to many people would lose injured going to that fight.
He said some pretty significant problems with his hands.
Something was up with them. He just seemed off and he was also, I mean,
I don't know how much of a factor that says,
but he also released a record with Wiz Khalifa. He was rapping,
he was doing his TMZ shows doing a lot.
And I love the fact that he's doing that because Tyron Woodley's a smart man.
He realizes he's in his thirties and how much more time does he have his
[inaudible]. He's very talented, very talented, very smart.
And his wrappings good man. I listened to his shit mindfully. He's good.
It's not cringey at all. No, it's fucking good. You could,
you could see him being a successful rapper.
100 will be successful in whatever he does.
Any funny does anything and he's smart. He's ambitious.
He's been in a thousand movies. He grinds as a fucking hard work and man,
but he wants a title back. Right. So he's on the grind right now.
Try to get that title back and the Po,
the beating that ou swollen put on him was fucking one of the motivational,
impressive performances, whatever. If Woodley had one arm or whatever.
But I didn't know that going in,
just seeing what he did to Woodley's got him down. I couldn't believe it.
I couldn't believe he looked like he broke him,
which was crazy cause even willing in the corner, he didn't would,
and I don't know if you had Woodley on since, uh,
he just didn't look like he was there. He wasn't present.
Like it didn't look like your normal world champion Woodley.
What is weirdly scheduled for a fight right now? I don't think so.
I think he's trying to heal up and have you, you know,
you're supposed to fight Robbie again. Yeah. But here's the other thing.
Did you know, you know,
remember Woodley had that whole kind of back and forth with the Dana and all
that. And I remember, um, I forget who he, he told this to,
but they asked him if you could do it all over again with the way you handled
the UFC, would you do it? And he goes, no. It was exhausting. I wouldn't,
I wouldn't do that again. What was exhausting fighting with UFC kind of,
you know, remember he was like Anti Dana. It never works out for anyone.
Does it? Well, I get their perspective that they want respect and you know,
they want to be treated like a champion. And you know, I,
I felt like my personal feeling was that he wasn't being represented correctly
in terms of the way they were talking about his fights.
100% I felt like he was fighting in,
especially me as a fan of tactics.
Like he was fighting Wonderboy for two fights and one, two boys.
The most difficult guy in the fucking sport to look good against.
He is so difficult to look good against. But the first fight, it was amazing.
It was great, great fight. And the one son,
he was the one who was doing the damage.
Wonderboy is one of the best strikers to ever fight in MMA.
He knocked Wonderboy down. He had Wonderboy hurt. Wonderboy never had him hurt,
but he fought and intelligent fight to deal with the tactics that Wonderboy
provides. Like you can't chase Wonderboy. You can't go after him.
He will fucking catch you with a counterstrike.
So what he did is he made Wonderboy lead, he weighed for his openings,
he stayed patient. It wasn't a lot of action, but when real delivered,
he opened up, he landed a fucking haymaker in the first fight,
had him really badly hurt.
He did the same thing and the second fight had him really badly hurt in a couple
spots. He's also one of the most active champion.
But you gotta be able to say that like if you're a fan of the sport,
like what I would say if I was in Dana white shoes and I was talking about that
fight, I would say if you're a fan of sport,
you got to understand that there are certain fighters where it's very difficult
to look good against.
I understand that if you're a fan and you want blood and you want chaos,
it didn't really quite live up to your expectations.
But that's not what this sport is all about. With this swap, the sport
is all about his two incredibly talented and well trained killers and they're
going after each other and they're both trying to figure out the openings to
win. And Tyron was able to win and he was able to win against one of the most
difficult guys in the division. And you know, does Damian do that? Did they? No,
they didn't.
But there's going to be guys where he looks amazing against like fucking Darren
till he made Darren show. He Shut Darren till down Darren till it's,
that's a shame to me that the Darren till's story right on his story is not
over. He's a young kid, but the way he was handled, and I know, you know,
they've exploded guys in the spotlight and it does work out. But that,
and that is the professional sports. That's UFC with Dan Tiller,
you look at all the talent that he had and it's just, they still got talent.
Oh no, he, he's going to be fine. He's so big. It's fucking tough.
I think he's cutting way too much weight to make one 70 I really do.
I mean he's that kid. You stand next to him. He looks like all I'd have you.
I've always been the guy who goes, man,
guys should grow up weight classes and now when Mac tolerate went to 55 against
us in poor dental, you know it was a good fight,
but it looks way better at 45 85 what?
Dustin [inaudible] going to one 55 made his career.
He was nine oh five he was struggling. He goes a 55 makes it clear. I know,
I mean I always [inaudible] at 70 there's a bunch of cases for it while Dos
Angeles at 70 those not one the title,
but he started off hot as fuck and he's running some problems but run into a lot
of really? Yes. He's running a lot of really tough guys.
Like Rockhold from 85 to two oh five I was shouting from the rooftops,
this guy that maybe can compete with Jon Jones.
And then he got in there and just look slow, lethargic, just different game.
He didn't look good like white man.
I think she'd be great at two Oh five but y'all [inaudible] look great.
You got to think about this was like a showcase fight for him and he's a big
fucking strong guy and when he clipped, fucking knocked him out for sure.
I mean Luke, Luke didn't look like himself. He looked slower. Hesitant.
He's had injuries. He's on model Bro. Yeah, he's a model. Like real money. Yeah,
but he's spraying like perfume and commercials. So Quinny doing,
making bank bro. Like fucking busted nuts I guess. So making banging,
busting nuts. That's what he's doing Joe.
But right now he's drinking through a straw. Yeah, I know shit. Yeah. I mean,
hey, that's why he wants to fight was jaw wired,
shut spray Cologne and buss nuts. It might be what he's doing from now on,
but when he, I think it is,
but when you're a world champion in the back of his head,
it's probably that feeling of being a world champion. When he beat Chris,
Chris Weidman probably the greatest feeling of his life,
but he's also had real problems with that Shin [inaudible].
They let him fight with that Shit anyways, kicking within shit. You know,
for people who don't know what we're talking about,
he had a massive staff infection, horrible.
And he had to get skin grafts on this shin and it's still fucked up.
Here's the thing about Luke though, and I love Luke. He knows this.
He's a friend of mine, but he's had a great long ass career man.
Like this is to me. That's when I said story. If Darren Tilden come champion,
that's a sad story.
Luke Rocco has been a world champion at Strikeforce and the UFC.
He smashed Machi too. He's beat some of the very
best guys in the world. He's a dying piece. He's fine. He's made his legacy.
So to me the shame is a guy like dear until if he doesn't bounce back. Yeah,
maybe.
But I think Luke Rockhold really believes that he could get back into the sa the
kind of form that he was in when he was world champion.
I just don't think you could ever make one 85 again and two oh five is a
different animal.
There are enormous men that are dropping down to two oh five and he looked like,
like he was carrying weight. He was jacked. It looks huge. It looked slow.
Yeah. He looked real slow. He looked angry. He got her thank you.
Get 20 extra pounds on you. That's what he likes around that.
You know what I'm saying? He walked around that way.
I think you might've put weight on to and to cut down to two oh five so it can
be a big two oh five and that might've been part of the problem to a five
Scandipop and these days. And we got a little sad,
his struggle city about a year ago. A lot of killers, a lot of killers,
but no one that is a real promising threat to Jon Jones.
Santos put on a fucking show, put on Chicago Song with one leg.
Yeah. And I knew it was nick leg blew out early on. I didn't.
And then when they told me he tore his ACL, MCL, everything,
and he still competed like that.
I could tell early in the first he threw something early in the first you could
see his leg go and I could you, you said something about it, right?
That's going on. Although I will say this as Santos is bad as fuck.
And then before that, Anthony Smith, both amazing fighters.
John's getting older. John's getting lower in that.
And I think there's a guy in, I think John's the greatest of all time.
Hands down. No argument. But he,
I think there's starting to be a little chink in his armor. Maybe. You think so?
Yes. You said bull with Santos there.
There were some Santos that fucking savage man Santos. A shit savage for sure.
And John fought him stand up for some strange reason. I was surprised,
especially with Santos,
his fucked up leg that John didn't take foreman stand blow me away by John by no
means. And Santos had one leg. I didn't understand that performance.
I don't know why he didn't take him down. Right.
I felt like John was one of the best wrestlers in the fucking sport.
He took down Daniel Cormier. He submitted fucking leave them a cheetah.
Vidor Belfour Rampage Jackson. Ryan Bader. He's amazing. Yeah.
He could take him down.
I wonder what was going on there and the guy's got one knee.
I mean you can't even walk. It's very straight. The game plan was very strange,
but I saw that went well and here, here's where I was thinking like that is,
will John go on defeated? Probably. I bet a good amount of money on that.
But there's a guy like, like uh,
I don't think you can sit on outside and beat John like a ray,
like a guy who's super technical and long.
You're not going out smart John on the outside. It's not happening.
I think it's going to come from a guy like Johnny Walker throws like a spinning
heel kick. Try and catch his giant. Someone good. Who's he? I fighting your boy.
He was just on the wrestler. The black dude. Oh Cory and Cory Anderson.
They were talking shit to each other. That didn't fucking New York. Ooh,
that's a good Cordy hat. Cory has crazy cardio. That's a great phrase.
He curtsy. What if Johnny Walkers, cause if you beat Coriann you're ready to go.
You beat him. We're going sizzler. Yes, yes. Or of Corey beats him.
He's going [inaudible] he's already there. Corey. Corey is already an elite guy.
Well he is an elite guy,
but he's not being talked about in terms of a title shot.
Very frustrating to him. Yeah. But that style is fucking hard to handle, man.
He doesn't matter. They're not in the business of that.
You put look at fucking look at Colby Covington. It's a similar style.
Just constant pressure. Yeah, you're right.
And you know he talks a lot of Shit Colby did to get there. Yeah. Well,
Cory's is a really nice guy and his guys finish last little shit.
Sometimes they win. Really? Yes in no, he can win for sure.
He's the dot's gonna take a lot of work though. Yep. To get there. Like,
like let's say you have a guy like let's say you have a guy who's um,
like a Conor McGregor,
he's gonna Catapult to the front before a guy you talking about [inaudible]
personality. Yes. Yes. Catapult. You have season. Go rocket ship. Go.
Isn't that crazy though? That's like part of the sport,
part of this sport is how much money can you generate because it's not just
about how well you perform as a fighter and about how many people were
interested in you. Fighting is crazy. It's crazy.
But that's the nature of the beast.
And that's why I hope that having a guy like Corey on my podcast or you having
him on your podcast that lets people know what a great God is,
says like this is the guy to root for. He's a great guy. Agree.
And he can fight his fucking ass off. I agree. But the casuals don't,
for whatever reason, they don't gravitate towards it. If he wins, they will.
Well, you just got to become undeniable. He slowly gets this.
He's slowly getting there and he's got one of the best trainers in the fucking
world. You know, mark,
Henry's the shit the best and his camp is fucking fantastic.
It's got Marlon and Frankie. He'll get a title shot. I think so too.
And you know who's another Nice Gal? Fucking lunch.
You better pack a lunch if you're fighting Corey.
But here's the way your nice guys don't finish last.
If the guy they're fighting is down to play the game via DC, John Jones,
DC's as nice as they come. He doesn't talk shit him for steep aid though.
Especially the first fight now. But that sales just off their talents.
But if you can get a guy like Josie Aldo, Conor McGregor chose ace,
nice as they come get this fucking Irish tidal wave and it looks like,
I'll watch that. And then Josie Aldo,
even though he's one of the greatest of all time at 45,
everyone tuned in and then he kinda took a lot of fans with him. Even,
even though he lost, he was a huge star. Yup.
That can happen for Corey with John Jones. Yeah. Although John John,
John Jones doesn't really talk shit. He's just a bad guy.
He'll sign in DC though.
Him DC hate each other dude saying John Jones DC for the heavyweight title.
I think that's the future you do. If Steve Bay wins in this, uh,
in this fight, that's next weekend tweak. I think that steep bay fights,
John Jones has heavyweight and Jon Jones moves up to heavyweight and tries to
win the title. Okay. Then do you see fights,
John Jones for the heavyweight title? When John's a champion,
if John can beat Steepbank or if Steve Bay can beat DC and then Steve Bay could
be Jon Jones and they have a admin depending on how the fight goes. Look,
the bottom line is DC,
not Steve Bay senseless one round knocked him out cold for the title.
What was it? A dominating fight. That doesn't mean it doesn't matter. Boom.
I'll close the lights. 100% channel shot. I'm cold. If he can beat him again,
man, and say John Jones, he's going to say she's smart. Yeah,
he does that. Oh God. Damn. Biggest fight in UFC history and heavyweight,
it will be enormous. What is this pound for pound Daniel Cormier.
Number two Khabib. Number three. Jon Jones. Come on, settle down folks.
Settle down. Whoever's doing that. Come on here, but I'll show you.
Let's say Jon Jones beat him twice. He's undefeated.
He's beaten every fucking human being he's ever competed against in real life.
Okay? Every single one. There's one loss in his career. It's a nonsense loss.
They're trying to reverse. I'm 100% support reversing that law.
At the very least. Make it a no contest. John dominated that fight.
Smashed Him. There is no fucking way. That's a loss. There's all CFC.
I'll just mark it as he's undefeated. How would he be knowledge? Undefeated.
Vomiting, knowledge. Fuck your athletic commission. I just met him last night.
Went watch the fight. Did you see Matt Hamill Talk Shit to John? Shit,
let's have a rematch. Like, whoa, are you crazy bro?
You won't lose your fucking vision to what,
dude? Just stop them. Ship this stuff. All that dude.
Hamill be cool though. Cool. Even John went, come on Bro.
He said to him, this just goes, come on Bro. I'll never fight.
It's not even a conversation about who's the light heavyweight goat is.
No conference. No, no. What are we talking about? No, John,
anytime talk pound for pound. John's clearly even that,
it's like only one was challenging for pound for pound was mighty mouse and
mighty mouse. You know,
the caveat was that he never beat anybody like Jon Jones beat.
It wasn't the same caliber. A fighter wasn't a DC.
And then when he lost a hammer, so udo go out with them. By the way,
super close fucking decision. Law Close could've gone that close.
Could've gone to mighty mouse. So in losses, a lot of loss losses, a loss.
It's like I see Demetrius Johnson and mighty Ma and, and uh,
and John Jones as being a, an argument for number one.
But after that there's no arguments and especially in light heavyweight,
there's no argument. Yes, Jon Jones,
everybody else can go pound sand. There's not, it's not even close.
I think John goes to heavyweight. Everybody's fucked too.
Although him hinders DC at heavyweight is so much more instant than light
heavyweight cause DC Knox do to help man. Right and John Jones,
if he goes up, who knows if he will have the same cardio,
who knows via the same if he'll be as fast.
There's something about guys going up like look, Luke Rockhold same,
same story.
He goes up to light heavyweight and he's got all this extra bulk on them. Now,
see,
I don't think John's going to go to like two 40 I think he's going to come in at
a fucking lean mean to 25 to 30 doesn't cut any weight.
That's what he trained that. Anyways, I was just fucking does work. Yeah.
Maybe he just comes in and looks just like John Jones at light heavyweight.
He just doesn't cut any weight and that's all. I mean, I don't know about now,
but especially back in the day when I was at Jackson's,
all he really did is go with heavyweights and we'll ragdoll ragdoll I'll tell
you what, when he fought, oh,
s p I talked to Jackson afterwards and Greg was saying,
I don't like the fact that he's been doing all this power lifting.
And he goes and I feel like that played a part in this fight. So Jack,
he did get [inaudible] but I don't, I didn't think that I felt,
I felt that it was OSP.
I feel like OSP rose to the occasion. He's a dangerous guy.
He's a super athletic guys big, he's got a powerful left kick, you know,
and he's an awkward fighter.
OSP fights awkward and you fuck up and he catches you with a leftover explosive,
impossible to take down typically guy man.
And yeah, I don't know,
maybe we're just not giving these guys enough credit because that's because we
think so high of John. Whenever it's close I'm like, ah,
cause John had enough nut that's maybe these guys are really fucking good.
I think OSP rose to the occasion. I have a lot of respect for OSP.
When I looked at that fight,
I was saying OSP fought a great fight and he fought with a fucking broken arm.
Okay.
You fought the entire last round with a broken arm and never even said a thing
about it. He was fighting with a fucking broken forearm. He's a beast.
He's a beast, and that's why I think John didn't look so good in that fight.
I disagree that he didn't look good because of the weight lifting,
but I don't know him the way Greg Jackson. Here's the caveat to that,
and I don't want to open this can of worms,
so that was also the first time he's been under strict testing.
That's what the naysayers are saying. Well,
that is the first time maybe a little Pico wasn't around
and hit it. Here's my defense of that being a Jon Jones Dick sucker.
Even with Pete,
you can fucking fill up anyone who he fights on whatever PD you want.
He's still being him. Whatever he's doing, whether he's taking things or not,
the you could give his fricking opponents as much as they want to.
They're not beating. It's a tough argument though. I'm saying. Yeah.
I don't know if that's necessarily true.
You fill up Tiago Santos full of fucking anti drawl 50.
He might run right down by that Brazilian [inaudible]. Yeah, you might be right.
I fucking, I kick his head. He might throw some fuck out.
Hey Doorbell for spitting tag. Who knows, man. I still think Joe, he just,
he's too smart. Too technical. I don't know. I don't either,
but we don't and we don't have to.
I don't have to know cause that testing is strict. Yeah.
I think I legitimately believe that what he got was through tainted means,
and I don't even know if it was supplements. You know,
the big theory was that he got cocaine that was laced with creatine.
I hope thing gets caught with creatine.
Apparently according to someone who I know who really knows their shit.
It was d, I mean there's not an ex, this is an expert. He said,
this is very common that when you buy cheap creatine, um,
cheap creatine often has other shit in it because you're buying it from China
and from other places that have unscrupulous mixing thing.
And I listen as one of the owners of Onnit. I know that this,
we never had our stuff test positive or steroids,
but what we did have is when we looked at the early batches of Alpha brain,
we had it independently tested. You know, when we first,
when Aubrey and I first opened on it,
we didn't know what the fuck we were doing in terms of we hadn't run a
supplement company before and there was a lot of learning to do.
And one of the things that we learned was that when you're buying stuff and then
you're having stuff mixed, the people that are mixing it,
if you don't get the very best people,
you're getting people that mix stuff that don't clean out their vats.
So you might get wind stroll in the gay. Anything in there. We never got shit.
I, we never got steroids in ours,
but probably cause with the stuff we're buying is nootropics, which are just uh,
nutrients that enhance brain function. So the,
the people that were selling stuff, we're selling similar things,
vitamins in the like. So,
but we did get our stuff tainted in a sense with other nutrients that weren't
supposed to be in there.
So then we had to do some investigation and then we figured out what the problem
was and we adjusted our methods and we changed the way we changed the people we
work with. And we did a lot of different things.
But if you're buying cheap creatine, that's what, that's what coke dealers use.
See, buy cheap creatives. Oh, you're saying a coke from a shady dude.
Guys buy a New Mexico coke. I'm not saying he is. It might be,
listen,
I've smoked some weed from some fucking shady people each and I'm a millionaire
to preach. People bring me some weed if they're my friend. I'm like, hey bro,
smoke some weed. You ain't lying. Yeah, I've ate some weird stuff. Yes, yes,
yes. Yeah. That's fair. Yeah. I don't know if I buy,
investigate everything I eat. No, never.
Dave Chappelle gave me some edibles the other day. I don't know where they ship.
They can throw in a bag. He probably made himself,
I pretty sure he ate mushrooms from a fan the other day. That so gangsta.
So we went to see a once upon a time in America.
I want to talk in the morning. Dave rented out the entire movie theater.
We do this fucking sold out show in the Tacoma dome.
We break the all time attendance record for the Tacoma Dome. 25,000 people.
It was a madness, right? We're flying high. It's insane.
It was an insane show. Who's the Elsa who opens for you guys? Well,
it's Ashley Barnhill. She goes on,
she does 10 minutes and then Ian Edwards goes on, murders it, and then I go on,
murdered it. It was a fucking crazy intermission. There's a,
DJ's got a hype man. Chuck a chalk jogs your wall.
People get drank in fucking lights and everything. It's madness. Okay.
Then don just goes on murders, murders.
Then Dave goes on lights, the place on fire.
Pisses gasoline on the flames. Then afterwards he and I go on stage together.
And what do you take to get Una with the crowd?
Don Males got a microphone and he's doing in the crop of 20 fucking 5,000
people. People are rushing the stage. It's madness. I mean man, it's,
what questions did you get? So random French bitch. People are just there.
Everyone's drunk. Sure. Dave. Hey,
the show is five hours old by the time this is happening. I'm not exaggerating.
We go on state.
The show's supposed to start at eight probably starts at (830) 910-1112 the show
was at least at least three and a half, four hours old by the time was over.
So the show ends like 1230 ish.
We go immediately from the arena straight to a movie theater that David rented
out.
We have a private screening of once upon a time in Hollywood at one o'clock in
the morning,
Dave's eating mushrooms that some fucking guy gave him in the crowd.
Did you eat them too? Oh fool me once.
Shame on you twice. Shame on me. Oh, is that us? Up there yet,
bro was nuts. It was nuts. You like the movie long at one in the morning.
We got out of there four 30 in the morning.
Then we get on a jet in the morning at 10 we fly to salt lake city and
immediately everybody gets a ivy vitamin drip with a date set up.
I own, yeah. B12 shots. These motherfuckers go rock style,
rockstar style.
Dave's got sunglasses on the entire time the whole crew was getting,
he has a potty with him. He brings his own photographer. It was madness. Legend.
I was like, okay, I see how you guys are doing. Oh, we get, by the way,
we get picked up at the, at the airport in a tour bus. It takes a tour bus.
10 minutes in a tour bus to the airport from the airport to the hotel and you're
flying privately. Why? Why? Why drive around in STV?
We could drive in a fucking tour bus for fucking, it's hilarious. Wow.
So much fun. How did this get, but this was what I was wondering.
So were you and Dave at the store and Dave was like,
who asks who like you're both titans. Dave called up my, well,
he called up his agent like I want to do a show with Joe Rogan.
And then his agent calls up my agent and they call me and I go, I'm in,
let's do it. And then then you guys texts out to Ellie kill. It's going down.
We didn't even tell them this is all business [inaudible] at the arena.
Well look, I love that guy. So he didn't know each other and we see each other.
He says, you know when, when they say it, I'm like, yeah, let's do it.
Oh it sounds like an awesome idea. And I'm free that weekend. Great idea.
It was only like five weeks out. The show sells out in 24 hours.
He doesn't have social media. No,
but that was the thing is that since he doesn't have social media and I do it
like magnifies everything because with all the fucking people that I have 7
million on Instagram and 5 million on Twitter, 2 million on Facebook, it's like,
oh that shit. And then the Po, I don't even think I mentioned it on the podcast.
We didn't think we had to have two. It's sold out.
So it's like secret shows that sell out in like 30 seconds. Exactly.
Well he does a lot of clubs and theaters and does whatever he wants.
He said he's a free bird. You know what I'm saying? Like he's free.
He just does whatever he wants. He wears his own clothes too. He does.
You notice that he's on his show, right? I love it, man. I can love it.
He's w he's living wild man. It's beautiful. You guys can do more together.
Yeah. Where are you scheduling them?
I can't say anything because they're not so schools.
So we had a great goddamn tied to what drives me nuts.
That's for any artists out there. Your guys is art and I s I I text you this,
you to take this everyone. You two are fucking legends, man.
For you to to get together and do shows is insane and to use like a shit that
mere or use to promote the shows drove drove me nuts. That's nonsense.
It's not though. Joke for the fans.
If you get a dope fucking artists do something like you and Dave Chappelle,
it's not for you. I'm sure we will in the future.
Any artists please may run off some tee shirts, uh, in Salt Lake City.
Just a small batch for the fuck of it. There's one, I sent a Jamie,
it's Jay z and m and M in New York like two times. Come together. Oh Man.
When I saw what you guys are posting, I was like, oh mother. Fuck yeah.
You worry about that too much. I don't know. I don't, I'm a fan and that,
that things at that, that's a history.
We'll iron that out because we're going to do a gang more of these so we'll iron
all that shit out. Hey, I'm sure Dave cares, but he doesn't have social media.
No, he doesn't give a funny social media closing though.
He doesn't even pay attention. He's,
he's the freest guy I've ever met in terms of not being locked into his phone.
He doesn't even look at his phone. I didn't even have it on him. Let's meet.
He's got a phone,
but he don't look at it and fuck with and he didn't care his phone calls,
you know, it's like he, he facetimes people and Shit.
He's not checking social media at all.
Did you learn anything from him just being around him? Well that is interesting.
Well this is what I learned.
There's levels to everything and he's on this like super celebrity rock star
level. That is really weird. It's really weird. But he's so nice.
He's so like, he's so fun to be around.
Like part of why Dave is so funny is because he's fun.
Like when you're around him it's not like he's serious and then he goes on stage
and then he's funny. No all day long is all day long.
It's like legs slapping and looking me in the eyes and fucking cracking and high
five and it's fun, man. He's a fun dude. But he's also,
he's very wise, he's wise in his approach to like for instance,
he lives in the middle of Ohio in a fucking farm.
And that's by design because he does away from all the noise to get away from
all the fucking noise. Man. He wants, you know,
he wants peace and quiet mixed in with these inner intermittent bouts of
madness. So he has these crazy radio city music hall shows.
And similar to you though. Well you don't live in fricking no, but I,
but eventually I'm going to move out of California. How dare you. Yeah,
no, not that much time, I think pretty soon. No. Yeah. You mean get a place,
but you're still going to be here. I'm going to eventually store and shit.
I'm gonna eventually move. Yeah. Yeah. For good. Yeah. Okay. I'm going keep,
I'm gonna keep a place here and uh,
I'm probably gonna still do shows out of this studio.
I'll fly in to do them like a,
probably wind up banking them like doing them in a week and then taking the rest
of the month off. Wow. Yeah. I don't want to beat, what about the store?
There's two, well, I love the store, but you know,
I also love the Improv and doing a lot of Improv shows. ISS is amazing.
I'm still going to do shows,
but I really think that there's something that's taxing about the volume of
people here that bothers me. Especially with kids when I yeah.
And when I came back from Italy and I was in Italy for 12 days,
when I came back like to the fucking highway at,
we landed at like 10 o'clock at night, just bumper to bumper on the three, five.
I was like this is stupid. This is stupid place to live. Cause I travel so much.
I mean I could travel out of Denver, you know,
I could live in Denver and travel out of their crowd as fuck too though.
Mine's bad. Not as bad month moving there. It's a beast.
It's blown up. It's a lot. Maybe Montana,
there's places to live that are more peaceful. Yeah.
But are you going to be satisfied not doing sets every night at the store, man?
Uh, there's no way. Like your happiness, you know what I'm saying? Like it's,
it's a weird balance cause I hear Ya, I hear you.
Where the balance for your family and stuff.
But like I check off boxes when I go out at night and I can,
I see like my, I don't, I don't, you're saying I don't hang out man.
I hang out the store when I see you there at the Improv,
when I see my friends or this is me hanging out, I checked those boxes on that.
I don't hang out man. And I need that for my own sanity. It's gated,
but I mean I feel like you can also get that when you tour, you know,
you can get that when you go on the weekends. I think I'd have to do more clubs.
I can't just do theaters because I really feel like it's a numbers thing.
Like in terms of a,
almost like if you're doing cardio or you can't do hard cardio once a week in
Spec, expect to be in shape. You,
you won't be in shape to do a bunch do it many, many times a week.
So if you're going to live somewhere other than La,
I feel like you have to do at least five sets a week.
I think that's the magic number.
So I think you'd have to do a weekend where you're doing two shows a night.
Friday, two shows a night, Saturday, and you'd have to do a week night.
So Monday and Friday. So yeah, you have to do something like that Thursday,
Friday, Saturday, or Friday, Saturday,
Sunday where you could open your own club in mind is better than Thursday.
Then Friday, Saturday, Sunday, Sunday can suck my dick. Yeah. Sundays at night.
That's the Lord's Day. Brahma, urban night. Right. Everybody's exhausted.
I don't do Sunday. Joey d isn't, I think you enjoyed his.
Told me never do Sundays. I did it once and I was depressed,
but also then I don't get a day off with my family. Yeah, not good.
I don't work Monday nights and then I don't work Sundays. That's my only rule.
Those are smart days. Yeah. Yeah. I'm the same way with you Sunday and Mondays.
I've been doing it lately. Yeah, and you got to do that.
You've gotta have those boundaries where you decide to take nights.
I'm going occasionally I'll do on Monday night, but most of the times, not.
Most of the time I take those off.
But I think there's a real benefit to not being overrun by the volume of people
out here. Is that what you do you think? That's why Dave,
one of the reasons he excels, you guys are similar with that, where you don't,
you're not really tuned in with like the masses meet meeting tune in where
you're not glued to your frickin no Twitter, Instagram,
he's not into going into like red carpet events and getting photos.
You hate that shit. But I just feel like it's a circle jerk, you know?
And everybody's just, you know, it's just weird. The, the,
the whole celebrity world is very weird. It's very weird.
But I get how people love when you're famous and then you're around other famous
people. They're the only people that think you're normal. You know?
They also understand what you're going through. Yeah. But it's like,
I ran into Jamie Fox the other night at a steak house. Again,
the rand nicest cancer down the most talented guy in the world. But, uh,
but when I see him, it's like, what's that? What are you doing? What's going on,
man. We talking and laughing and joking around. I'm like, he's,
he's never weirded out. He like, he's so famous. He's like,
he's probably never gets a chance to be a normal person unless he's around other
famous people. You don't want a picture or an autograph or some,
you know that movie you did? I'm like, man. Yeah. Yeah. I mean he,
he likes to just hang out and have fun.
I wish you'd get them back on the podcast. He wants to do it.
We were talking about like a real long form podcast this time.
He was like pushing a sunglass assumption. Oh yeah, that's right.
He had a sunglass deal. Who's dealing and he's even doing that a great story.
No, I don't.
Probably shackled out some fucking shutter to serious Jamie fucks and those
bullshit sunglasses. Yeah, man. It was him and Jeremy Pivot.
They were pushing sunglasses, assumed him and put them together.
Live those sunglasses. Pavements. No, no sunglasses. I don't think.
I don't think, no, no. They, the company answer all that snow. Yeah. Yeah.
The thing I think fizzled out,
but you gotta figure Jamie Fox to push some classes.
You think you need money from your fucking sunglass sales.
They had to pay him fucking bang.
Can I tell him every time I ran to him and a gas station,
some guy pulls up in a fucking car that doesn't even look like it's from this
planet. [inaudible] some strange SUV, some weird fucking,
I dunno what it's called, but I looked at, I was like,
what the fuck is on those apocalypse tank? We are weird looking thing.
It's, I forget what it's based on.
It's based on like the frame of a jeep wrangler and they build this insane,
you know like $500,000 fucking SUV on it. I'm like,
who is the window roads down? What's up Joe? It's Jamie Fox. I'm like, oh,
what are you doing Django? I'm like, what is this?
And his friend was selling them. His friends sell those.
Probably gave it to Jay. We didn't try for sure. We sold. Yeah.
Almost like this is the craziest thing we've ever seen. It's so weird looking.
You know what it is like boxy. Right. But then they have squeaky little lights.
I'll even find it. Yeah. Just me.
Fox crazy SUV is expensive. Jeep wranglers. But I got so far. Why? I know this,
I don't know, but it's a, uh, Chris Brown
drives when the new,
his new video where he dances with the house or whatever too. Yeah.
They probably given them away to people or sure. As Vani. Yes. Yeah. Let me see.
Let me see what that pitch looks like. Yeah, they're sick. Yeah,
that makes sense. Give it to Chris Brown. You know his video. That's it. Yeah,
that's it. That's exactly, I think so. Cool.
Look at that thing. It's not, it's a, it's fucking robocop.
Like it's dope though. He pulled up, ah,
got the suicide doors in the back and the interior is gorgeous.
The engines made based off a jeep wrangler. I don't know what it is.
I don't know what it is yet. There, there you there?
That's a dope ride, man. Yeah, it's really incredible. But I hear,
I want one. I mean, they're real expensive, right?
I'm 50 180 so I'm like, oh, oh, that's not that bad. Not Terrible.
I thought it was like a half a million, maybe two. I was going,
I thought at least three 5,500 horsepower efficient.
180 wow. Isn't it funny that 500 horse probably used to be insanity?
Me and my brother were talking about this on that. My brother is a huge car.
We're talking about this and I just got my uh,
Freud over 800 and I mean Jay phrase,
I just got my four run over 800 so ridiculous horsepower, so ridiculous.
Here's the thing, they're going to come out while they, the TDF in,
they have a TDF version of mine. They only be six on the DF. It's the,
the s like the souped up a virgin of mine. It's the race version.
They only made 600 of them and that comes stock with like 817 horsepower.
But then they then for I went, cool story.
We're coming out with eight 12 super fast V12 tents for the Tour de France,
but they can't call it the tour to fancy stuff called TDF cause Tour de France.
The fucking the [inaudible]. The bike boys own it.
Did you see that shit where this guy had a super fast and he's apparently a very
famous designer and he put his sneakers on the roof of this dope fucking Ferrari
that he owns. He owns this crazy green Ferrari. Super fast. Yes,
it's gorgeous. And he put his sneakers,
which are green as well on the frog and Ferrari sent him like a cease and desist
and they threatened him.
This Guy Philip plein lashes out a frog overseas and does this letter but like
look at the photo. It's an alligator jacket. Look CEO's.
Apparently I asked my wife and this guy is a fit. Look how dope that color is.
I'm not usually in the a green car that that lizard green looking amazing.
It makes the GT three in it, but that's, I like the metallic. Yeah,
there's like the hot electric green. Yeah.
See if there's any other pictures of his car. But look at that.
He's got these dope sneakers and they're sitting on his Ferrari and Ferrari was
angry. They were like, you're using our brand or something like that.
Oh because w I'm trying to think cause he painted green.
Then are those his shoes and it's with the Ferrari so that like can be said for
robberies,
trademarks and model cars are are associated in your pictures with a lifestyle.
Totally inconsistent with Ferrari's brand perception in connection with
performers
making sexual innuendos and using Ferrari cars as props in a manner which is per
se distasteful.
This behavior tarnishes the reputation of Ferrari's brands and causes Ferrari
further material damage.
In fact the undesirable connection between Ferrari's trademarks on the one hand
and Phillip Cleans Line of shoes and the questionable manner in which they are
promoted on the other hand is interfering negatively with the rights enjoyed by
Ferrari's selected licenses which are exclusively entitled to use Ferrari's
trademarks to produce and promote line of shoes for our bread as non.
That's why I love for I [inaudible] branded shoes. Fuck yeah they do. They sell,
you know they sell more Mertz than cars. They make their money off merge.
But this guy is a very successful designer.
His stuff is very expensive. It's like Ferrari. No,
you get that Shit Outta here. That shit fry. Holler to boy halter boy.
Nah, I'm just kidding dude. No. Here's the thing.
He probably got allocated the super fast cause you can't,
you know how Friday where she can't just walk in the store and buy one.
So you got allocated one. So he probably owned other V12.
It's a crazy lots like Ferrari's for 10 years. He said, there you go.
So he gets allocated the new ones. So he probably had access to the TDF.
Then he got a super fast and then in painted green like an asshole,
which cool color green. Now he can't, well he might've had it may paint a show.
I don't know. I don't think fry offers that green. He tried. No, no way. No,
he did that to himself. That's why Fry's like Jesus Christ. Dude, be cool.
Really? Yeah. You don't think Ferrari offers that color? I don't think so.
I wouldn't doubt it. You ever seen another fry? If they did,
he probably paid such a premium for that color cause they don't make that color.
Well, the only one I've seen in the flesh is yours.
I've never seen one of those cars before. Yeah. Yeah. Well,
I see one of them at a dealership. I saw a,
there's only 700 of them in the states. I saw a, uh, gray like that.
Battleship gray. God, it made my Dick Card.
Certain cars do. Man, I want so many cars. I know. It's crazy, right? Yeah,
man. It's a problem with cars. I'll tell you that. I love,
I absolutely love Ferrari. I'm a fro. I love Ferrari.
There's nothing like a Porsche. I owe it. I've terms of driving Bentleys.
You named. I've had all the cars.
There's nothing as far as the driving experience, but in the Porsche. Yeah. No,
I think I have to always have a portrait.
The reason why I still have that 2007 gt three Rs,
the char quirks worked on every discards ever. Every time I get in there,
I get happy. It just feels amazing. It's just [inaudible]. Wow.
And also can feel him.
I want a goddamn manual transmission to the portion is the last of the Mohicans.
They still don't do it though for the gt three Rs and they still don't do it for
the gt two rs, the Gt three Turing,
the Gt three and the gt three touring. They'll,
they'll sell you with a manual trends, which, which is what, yeah,
I want to get one of those to the new corvette. Abandoned
the manual. I know. Fast as fuck. No, that I agree. Comment.
I mean, you drive a Tesla but so,
but the corvette to me it looks bad as they completely ripped off Ferrari.
I mean that's a, I mean, come on some mid engine car. Mid Engine car. Yeah,
but I have a 65 corvette with a giant Hirsch shifter with a fucking cue ball.
The cue ball shift. That's the real guy. That's America. I know.
I not pipes bitch. I know. Oh, I don't want one of those Corbett's though.
They look cool, but I don't want dope man.
You when the Zr one comes out and it goes zero to 16 three milliseconds.
It's not all about zero to 60 I'm not vin diesel.
I don't live my life one quarter mile at a time.
Guess who else is in Vin diesel? Vin Diesel. Yeah, you right. You right fucker.
Wear sunglasses at night. Yeah, he does. Yeah, he does. You know he's going to,
he's quietly becoming a billionaire from the fast and furious franchise cause he
owns it. Yeah. So like, yeah, tis so like universal, the rides and all that.
He's quite becoming a billion is probably in a castle somewhere doing Caligula's
shit and fucking dudes.
You don't get those vibe from him. Even when he's in the life beater,
like barbecuing all the time. He's barbecuing and passive beers. I do too,
but in a beater for a wife, Peter, my wife yells at me.
She doesn't let me wear those. I could go shirtless. Rightfully so.
Rightfully so. If I have a wife beater on,
she'll start making fun of me. That's given, it's so old to go.
Remember that video? What's he done by fucking thing in the Beyonce? Oh,
there's nothing better than that going viral. What's going on with his pants?
Why they're so low. I can't, I'm not gonna show up.
I just went viral on the show. Joe Doe drunk in love.
What is he doing? This is the longest three minutes.
He made it himself and we can't play this. The song will get it.
They can hear the audio. Those unnecessary. Just the dancing is on this dude.
He's celebrating like his movie. You went, I don't know,
platinum or some shit like that, so he does drunk in love.
He does a cover of him singing kit. Kill this before. Throw it. Can you hear it?
Listen, I'm on team rock. You do not leave here one quarter mile at a time.
If you're doing that. I'm on team to rock all day every day.
He's feeling himself in the block. Don't get along. They hate each other.
How does that, everything happened there.
I heard Brock was a big deal on set clock diva.
That's what I heard from who people. What'd you hear that are in the,
that were on the set? Just that, you know,
the rock sometimes shows up late and there's trailers and he wanted the biggest
trailer and obviously been diesel. You know, he's Mr fucking fast and furious.
Who knows who's right. Listen, he just did Beyonce cover. So I don't know.
16 rules. Yeah, let's kill that team.
Rock kids fast and furious have to follow onset. What? There's rules.
Certain guys can't get hit a certain amount of times.
They have to win fights and certain ways, you know though,
you know the rock and go back to that, that sounded, just go back to it.
[inaudible] you know, but this isn't the best.
Do you have to go to racing school in Las Vegas? That, that makes sense.
That doesn't look fast and fierce, but you know, the rock of indies will,
couldn't be on set at the same time. They hate each other so bad.
They just shoot different scenes and like, like shoot it.
So it looked like someone was there. They hate each other so much.
The Rock gotten a big thing with Tyrese too, right by tires.
Just flipping out because like all he has is fast and furious so that when the
rock did a spinoff, he's like, how dare you? We're a family. Rock was like, no,
we're not. Well Damien spin off dumb ass.
But remember when the Rock was shitting on his music? That was fantastic.
Let cause rock is so positive.
Tyrese Gibson reignites fast feud with Dwayne Johnson calls spinoff.
Hobson Shaws not a win video. Why is he crying? He went crazy.
He went crazy for a shine. This is all I've got and he has will Smith for money.
That's what he's mad about.
Why do you Ras will Smith for money fell on hard times. He said, yeah,
the video. Here's the thing. People lose their mind, man.
The actors really lose their mind.
They will quit cause you're pretending to be someone else all the time.
Separate the rock. Not good for you. That guy, you know what he does?
He just goes to the gym. The rock with two hours sleep. A lot of steroids. Yeah,
Thick Gel. Do you really think he's getting big like that from cocaine again
and again? He used to cocaine. No, I'm saying the Jon Jones thing,
but I'm just saying like anyone, it, me,
me and Burt cries. We're talking about this thing. Burt's can make a bit of it,
but when you see the Rock, you know how this is working out?
Two hours of sleep for sure. He's doing that stuff, man. He's grinding.
He's on private jets.
He is loaded on performance enhancing drugs too.
So his body is pulsing.
As your boys are going statutes say with fuck,
I don't know Bro. I don't know. I don't know Bro. Jason, stay them in the rock.
Refuse to lose fights against one another. Jason State them. Come on Bro. Uh,
Jason settled down. Yep. How about you bro? How about you?
Really fighting in that determines what happens. You weigh 170 pounds.
He used to be an Olympic swimmer. You know that he's a bad motherfucker though.
Jason stayed them. But the rock is an enormous human. Well,
how are they the same height there? That doesn't make any sense.
That's just strange. Is he on a box? That doesn't make any sense. Okay.
[inaudible] egocentric demands are nothing new on how,
first of all we don't know if this is true and this is the Guardian,
which is kind of a nonsense website, so let's just stop reading.
It's interesting though and then you'd know it's also probably true behind the
movies here he's told the Wall Street Journal paywall that actors including
Jason's t them Dwayne,
the Rock Johnson and Vinnie's off contracts demanding that limit the amount of
punishment.
There's characters taking fights because they don't want to look like bitches.
You imagine telling your agent that like I'm down to do it. Bam.
I read through the script when he punches me in the face,
I'm not going down bro. I'm not doing it. You imagine doing that.
That's so crazy. Thank you for your group of friends. Where around you like,
dude, what the fuck are you doing? What's up Jason?
Diesel sisters report to have been president on set asking for her brother was
going to get his licks back in that could she been joking around?
My sister might say that too. If she saw me in a movie, get my ass kicked,
cause fuck him up. We'd play laughing together, slap her in the face.
Can I get my licks back in?
We know it's fake bitch talking about I'm also making $100 million.
You'd whip my ass every seen for that money.
It's funny when a movie franchise just gets bananas huge like that.
Just so big and vin diesel is like, yeah, cool man.
But he's always doing a million things at once.
I have never seen or is he just doing facet? What else is he doing bro?
Well he's got a television show. Well, yes he does. He's in diesel. Yeah,
like a a game show. Fear factor type television show.
He is always doing something. He's also doing Jumanji. He did a new Jumanji.
You talking about the rock? Oh, you don't have to rock rock. What'd you say?
Vin Diesel. They're all, he does videos. He goes, I'm going to make $1 billion.
Suck that David ds or the rock you said Vin diesel. I'm sorry, drunk.
Unless he's fixing the rides at universal studios is always doing a million
different things at once. Always. He's got borrowers on HBO,
he's got 'em that that TV show that he does,
which is like some crazy fucking fear factor type deal. He's got Jumanji,
he's always filming a million different [inaudible] movies. Here's the thing,
do that again. To my point, lot of steroids,
lot of before Anson drugs and I'm all about it. I have no problem with this,
but let's tell the kids like it is like, I thought Arnold was an, I was like,
man, hopefully I can get there one day. If I keep it in the gym, I wish my dad,
I'm like, ah, it's never happening man. We got to inject some shit in your ass.
Forgot to vin diesel. Listen in the Avengers. What? What? He's crude.
Oh,
he's the voice of due to the Gow cause I take some 30 minutes,
I take some 30 minutes to do that. Yeah. Um,
you know what else does that trip that I did with Chappelle that opened my eyes.
Do you ever done when those things are done? Ivy Ivy violence.
Whereby in brother I swept it up a bag and a half and I was ready to run through
a wall. And it was three hours from your house? Yeah, they'll come anywhere.
They came to our hotel room. Yeah, I get them at the crib all the time.
My girl's pregnant again. We have another one coming November and uh,
for the nausea we, we get ivs, I swear. Oh Dude. Two night and day.
It's amazing for like pumping you up [inaudible] Vegas side to get it.
What'd you, we had a,
you had a show there and like I showed up wasted I think type of like the New
Year's eve UFC. I like to wake up when I had to get it had to get done.
You felt so much better minutes. 20 minutes. I was good to go. It's crazy.
It's crazy. You know what's crazy to me is the UFC doesn't allow, well,
it's feels so good. You can mask the use of performance enhancing drug haters,
Bro. God speaking to performance enhancing drugs.
Let's
talk about the Cyborg situation. I knew you're going to go there.
How about that? See Dana go hard in the paint.
You know what I like when he goes hard in the paint? He's, he only got listen,
say what you want about Dana and I do like it. Like we always say,
can you imagine if another commissioner did this? Another owner did this,
but I do like when he does spit the cause. What he's saying is the truth.
Like sometimes he's on one and you're like, what the fuck you talking about?
You're screwing these guys over. Then sometimes like with the cyber thing,
when you send that to me, like I agree with them 100% I love when he does that.
Well, they fucked up and they really fucked up.
Let me try work's team Cyborg's team, whoever did it,
whether it's her boyfriend or whoever it was that edited that video that lied
and put words in his mouth is so fucking stupid.
You don't think that they're going to do something about that.
You're out of your goddamn mind when they edited that video to say that whenever
I'm talking public, I'm not telling the truth, which is not what he said at all.
And then to have it edit and cut right there. Well,
I'll tell you this right now, Dan, Dana's too smart it, let's say he would,
let's say he thinks that you think he would say that in a public form to Cyborg
when they're face to face like that.
And you don't think you realize there's cameras around. No,
he's way too smart for that. So eight that I'm like, well,
he's not that dumb be that video was, you can tell it's so full of shit.
Same thing happening with, with me and Nate Diaz had our confrontation.
I didn't say any of that stuff. Someone made that all up. Yeah.
Well what also they did was they're bringing back shit that happened five years
ago. Like Cyborg was saying.
She wanted an apology from me and I don't think it was that she wanted apology
from me. I think it was her boyfriend or someone on a team. I apologize to her.
Me and her.
No one around face to face and I took a photo with her afterwards.
There's a photo of me and her on my Instagram. Would you say you're just like,
hey, me and my guys were shooting around starting on fighting in the UFC.
She hadn't fought in UFC before and I said, Hey, I'm sorry about the jokes.
I promise no more jokes. And I said,
I am actually a fan of yours and I want you to succeed in the UFC and I wish you
the best of luck. I go, no hard feelings. She goes, no, those, you know,
those jokes kind of hurt my feelings and I said, I'm sorry. I go,
I promise no more jokes.
I gave her a hug and we took a picture together and that was a, when was that?
2017 here's the only time where I'm like,
God damn man is sure kids getting bullied at school because of the,
didn't know she had a kid. Oh yeah, yeah. How many kids did show up?
She has one daughter I think in like fourth grade and she goes because of the
narrative that the UFC painted, right or wrong. I get it from the UFC side.
Doesn't mean to try narrative that she's this heel.
She's this monster pds, right? Yeah,
but that's because she tested positive once. We don't talk about John Jones,
he's talks about possible more than once.
First of all there's Jon Jones got tested positive for this tiny amount of
something that probably came from a tainted supplement.
She tested positive for a serious steroid and something that you,
you're like a woman taking a steroid is different than a man taking a stone with
a takeout female male, which is tough to do here, but it is. There's,
there's been people who have tested positive before where that's not their
narrative. Brock Lesnar. Yeah, but it is Brock Lesnar's narrative.
It's also Alister Overeem's narrative. Is it,
is it beats or is it t r t v to u of C doesn't tell you that though.
They're not market.
The fans do kind of marketing the fact that Stipe's hardware was taking
steroids, that oh,
their market are into this kind of heel roll dog where if you know her,
she's awesome. But no, the marketer's destroyer,
which she is in her career is scary and destroy, but also, yeah, in a good way.
Look, if you look at her fights, you look at the fight with, look,
the way it gets dark is when you go back to the non testing days like the Gina
Carano fight,
which had veins coming out of her face and she looked like Gina Chrono murder.
This sweat. My argument for, I don't mean to interrupt you,
but Gina Carano ate the hottest Chica to ever fight MMA.
B fought Cyborg when she was juiced to the Gills and did pretty well.
They put go back and watch her at one point,
but eventually out to Gina Chrono eventually got beaten down and there's a
video.
There's a picture rather of Cyborg holding Gina's face and punching her and you
see the black fingernails and she's got this mean look in her face and she's
punching Jean in the face as I bring this one up. Jamie,
you ever seen that picture? I've never seen it, dude. It's,
it's one of those pictures. It was the demise. No, no, no.
It's a standing photo of a Cyborg punching.
Is it that one French? No, no, no, no, no, no, no. Go left. Go left.
That's French. I love that one about friendship. Bam. That's the photo.
So look at the black thing. Grab her face like the end punter. Jesus Christ.
The end of the fight. I mean, she's already beaten her down,
but I mean she's holding her face with those black fingernails and just crushing
Gina's head. She beat the shit out of her, but debt. Gina was a beast man.
And she hung in there as long as she could.
But the consensus was that Cyborg was juiced up in that one. That one. Right.
You mark it as beauty and the beast. Right. That's just the way it is.
Gina's a gorgeous individual. Cyborg,
not so much when it comes to the, the feminine,
like the Looks Department. So I get that market beauty and the beast.
I was taught, I had a Kyla Harrison on, you know who that is? The BFL.
She's a two time gold medalist. A judo judoka Kayla, right? Kayla Harrison.
Yeah. Monster. And uh, she wants,
she's in the PFL and she's in the tournament there and she's, uh,
she wants to fight Cyborg. Yeah.
Well there's a lot of people that are wanting to fight. She definitely wants,
right. Undefeated gold medalists. And I was talking to her about why does,
why does she think that kind of Cyborg has gone down this road in her career?
And then I pitched her on, you know, if I found the UFC in here,
this might be completely fucking wrong. I don't know.
But this is how I would do it and this is what they're doing is what I think.
But if I'm the USC, as Nice as a person Cyborg is,
there's no other girl walked in this plant that looks like Cyborg really because
maybe pds to your point or there's a light. When you say maybe like most likely,
that's what I'm saying. Yeah. I'm trying to be cool. I'm trying to be nice.
I know you're trying,
there's a lot of girls that look like paint fans and there's a lot of girls like
Paige vanzant or Rhonda Rousey or Misha Tate,
so they're going to push those girls more because that's what people can relate
to more than a girl like Cyborg and I don't think I'm saying anything.
No one has assumed already and this, and I liked Cyborg,
the nice person and I don't think Cyborg is a bad person.
I think her management and the way they've handled things have completely fucked
her and I think you're going to battle with the was the worst thing and it's not
hurt. I don't think it's hurt either.
And I think she is a nice person and every time I've ever phenomenal,
fine interacted with her, I've been luck.
Even that last fight and that was a thing with the Spencer fight like that,
people were saying that, oh you guys, it was biased commentary. No, it wasn't.
That girl survived.
That girl said [inaudible] you're the greatest calm.
Taylor will turn eighth pro fight
ten eight round Cyborg beat duff. Fuck out of her dude. Don't fight.
Wasn't close. No, no, no. It wasn't close,
but the narrative was how tough she was. I'm like, sidebar, he's beaten up,
bragged on this girl and she cut cyborgs face wide open one with one elbow. Yes.
Gives a fuck. She got beat up the rest of the fight.
There's the idea was that she was going to run through that girl and she didn't,
that girl was tough as shit wasn't, it wasn't a competitive fight,
but she doesn't have striking that was on the level of,
she doesn't have power to keep cyborg offer. She just does.
Cyborg lit her up like your Christmas tree.
She got though there was ten eight rounds and I was like, oh that fights.
I'm close.
No it's not gonna I feel you guys cause it's the Jon Jones things when you go
into a fight it's like when John doesn't destroy someone.
You're talking about the other guy and was sidebar to you expected just a Merck?
This cargo Santos was way closer. I mean that was a way closer fight.
Thiago Santos was a 1.1 some rounds. Well this is a split decision for sure.
Yeah. Some one judge thought that Tiago won the fight.
I don't agree with that challenge but that's how close that fight was.
There was no one that thought that Spencer won that fight after it was over.
But it was amazing that she was able to endure the fucking beating this I've
were put on her. It was incredibly tough girl. None the saying no,
but it's actually one of those fights where it really like no one's clamoring
for that fight in the first place. Who was asking for that fight? Not me.
Other than her. Yeah. I'm excited for the fight card next weekend in him.
Cause the cards. I don't know if you agree with this.
The cards up to this point of being dog shit. The main events have been good,
but other than that they've been Gotcha. But I think you're doing homework.
There's so many. The main events have been great. Other than that been awful.
Carts Anaheim. This can be amazing. Again. What else?
Who else fought this past weekend? I looked at the card.
I mean I don't know what to say. Other fights in the undercard.
There was some good fights. [inaudible] mailers, clique. Guido was wild.
Jim Mueller, quick widow. It was fucking wild. That was wild.
But in terms of like title implications, yeah, this is the big one this weekend.
[inaudible] you got Yo Romero next weekends as Paul goes next. Next,
next weekend. Yeah. Yo El Ramiro versus polar coaster,
which is best body contest of all time. First team. All diamond. Yeah.
Amazing fight too. I mean Kosta is just on a fucking rampage to golden snitches.
Just like Bella's. Yeah. Yeah fellas. Well, the deal,
Yo, Al was the freak of all freaks. You know what I mean?
He is the freak host is no punky. There was no body. No both of them.
Both of them were beasts. That's an amazing fight. As long as the bay DC,
which to me is so interesting.
You know what to it wasn't that interesting to me too.
I came on her a wild few months ago and you're talking about it and I'm like,
that is a really good fucking fight because if you go back and watch the first
fight with Steve and DC, DC wasn't dominating and then clipped him,
you know, and Steve Bay said time Steve pays a motherfucker.
Like that's a really good fight man.
Well I don't like the long layoff for steeping was good bite.
The reason why I like it is he was coming off of that fucking crazy war with
Francis and Ghana where he took some big shots, particularly in the first round.
How impressive is that now that my nails let Francis capable. Yeah,
and Francis knocks everybody dead and steep is the only guy not to just,
just to survive Francis, but to beat him. He figured it out like a champion.
Got Him to the ground, you know, neutralized all his weapons and beat him.
I think,
I think d C V or I think Francis for Steve Bay would be different this time.
I think.
I think Francis has made leaps and bound improvements to his grappling and
confidence and he's not so a rockstar reckless lifestyle.
And his ego's in check, like you sit and talk to him like,
Oh fuck this guys tuned in, man. Yeah. I mean,
it's a look and he knows what's at stake now with Daniel, you know?
And Daniel knows too. I mean,
Daniel's treating it like he's about to fight the greatest heavyweight of all
time. You know, that's his approach. I mean,
that's what he said to me behind the scenes. And uh,
but he just thinks he's better in every way and he thinks he's going to beat him
again. And [inaudible] thinks he just got clipped with that one punch.
If he doesn't get clipped with that one punch, she wins that fight.
You know what? I'll take both arguments. Yeah, you're right. You're right.
Let's see what happens then. Fuck knows. It's such a great phasing.
Amazing fight. And then you've got pat s versus Nate Diaz, which is Saturday,
right? Yeah. Well that's an interesting look.
Nate doesn't want to cut any weight and pat has just knocked out Wonderboy,
so he's like, fuck it. Let's do this. Pedis.
Last fight was against a Tony Ferguson, right? Wonderboy,
Wonderboy knocked out
Wunderbar Tony Ferguson was before that first one was at 55 and pedis his first
fighter at 70 I mean, look man, when you, when you've been starving yourself,
you get to 45 and 55 and then finally fight at one 70 and you knock Wonderboy
out with a superman punch. You gotta say, maybe this is my weight class.
The only question when Nate Diaz and I would assume Nate dia, or, I'm sorry,
Anthea pedis is a favorite cause Nate Diaz ended up font.
No hot fucking seconds. Here's the favorite.
I bet Nate's even at every pedestal. The favorite. Yeah. Please check.
Let's check in terms of, you think Diaz would be the favorite? Yeah, I think so.
Doing kicks from Anthony Pettis. Well, I think gambling
right? Well, I think, I think pat is the favorite. Okay.
Maybe you might think pedis is the favorite in terms of the way you view the
fight. But when you think about favorites,
favorites depend upon who's betting for who.
And I think it's going to be a shit ton of people betting on Nate Diaz ideas as
an army behind. Yeah. Other than put money down, huge star.
He is one of the least.
He's like the worst promoted superstar him,
him and his brother.
They can imagine China minus minus one 25 minus one 25 Pederson.
Nate's even money and pedis is minus one 30. Okay. That's it for today.
We'll see what it happens. Layoff. Yeah, I agree. It's gonna be,
I bet I bet them you're probably right.
The money because Nate Diaz is so famous. The money's going to go his way.
What else is on the claws?
Pull the rest of the card up so we can see the rest of the card because it's a
great card even on top of that. Um, what else we got here?
Derek Brenson site. Yeah. Let me get a little dicey after those top three,
but I feel you. But this is probably more on the ESPN card.
Let's see what else you got with the ESPN card. Yeah. Oh,
my board's slurry to Hagen telling you versus a Sun Sal.
That's a great for that. For him that he beats him your seat to me.
When I talked about guys who are gatekeepers there,
I don't believe in the term gatekeeper. We're like, Yo, you get the top 10.
The guys in the twilight of his career, to me gatekeepers, you beat him.
You get title shot, son sells that guy. Few beat him.
You gotta fight one or the champ number one or champ.
And that's where Sandy Hagans right at.
What did you think about a Marla Mariah's submitting a Sun Sal?
I mean that was pretty crazy. Amazing. But then how much did you learn from,
you know Marlon Mariah's, his last fight, where your lost?
We got kinda got broke, man. I thought, I wonder what was happening there.
I wonder if it's stress of the fight, if that's what made him fatigue.
Here's what you got to pay attention to is when Mark Henry,
who's to me the best coach in MMA and him or for us when he's in the corner and
he, he must have seen in trainer and something because he goes,
think about your mom. Don't give up. Think about your fucking mom.
What took you to come here when a coach has to pull out that fucking yellow card
after the first round, he's thinking, yeah, that's why I'm like, oh,
he's quitting practice before. Now mark decked me if I'm wrong,
but I assume that he's seen some sort of quit in him in practice.
When you gotta think about your mom after the first round,
you go zero to a hundred thinking about your mom's a rough.
That means he saw something that he's seen in practice before he went, oh fuck.
There it is. No, no, no dude, dude, remember you met your fucking mom.
What took to get here and stilled in and work?
The crazy thing is if you saw that first round, you thought,
and Mirage is the best fighter in the world. Yeah, like my God.
So who though doesn't even belong in here today? You're so screwed. Yeah.
I'm like, so who does fucked, how good his skin, his legs destroyed.
He just look, you had an injury, unstoppable belief in himself, unstoppable.
He just believes in himself past reality.
He's arguing right now these pound for pound in the world because gold medalist,
then two division champion. You had some work to do though. My mouth says,
hold my little bear. I beat a shitload of dudes. They're tiny.
They're tiny. You know, they're tight,
like a little fucking diet coke can this little,
those little baby ones you get when you go to a kid's party, like yeah. Yeah,
that's a, it's not a good argument in terms of him being the best of all time.
But in terms of being the one of the greatest combat sport athletes all the
times, the shore,
Olympic gold medalist and then UFC champion in two different way classes.
I mean fuck, but the thing about that, uh, Kayla Harrison,
who's a two time gold medalist,
if she were able to get a championship over and PFL come over the UFC two gold
metals, that's nuts, dude.
But she will not be fighting the same caliber of fighters that Henry Sudo
fought. No, that's, that's just where the females are at. Right.
And it's just where they're at.
Unless she fights Valentino Schiff Chanko or Amanda Nunez though she trains with
Amanda. Amanda's gonna retire by the time she gets to the UFC.
Amanda Nunez and Valentina Shevchenko or as good as any fucking male fighter on
the planet, especially Valentino striking foul.
Tina is so she's assassin. She's so tactical.
What's Amanda Nunez do now? Cause hurt. Cyborg was the fight.
I still think they make the cyborg fight, by the way. Absolutely.
Don't you think Dana's going to do it? Well, he said it. He would do it.
He's like, I'll do it.
Fucking coffee or one fight contract if she wants to do what she could do.
But she does not want to fight Amanda Nunez. Look to take Dana Smart,
all that shit that he said. Oh,
he calls me up right now and she says she wants to fight Amanda Nunez.
I'll make the fight. He goes, but she's not gonna do it. So he said,
if she calls me up, I will make the fight putting the ball in her court.
Pass it still. Don't worry.
That's not going to happen this cause you [inaudible] she's gotta be devastated
by that video. Whoever made that video, I don't know who it is.
You don't know who it is. I know it wasn't her.
She didn't make that stupid shit.
She doesn't tweet her boyfriend tweets for so exhausted. It's just complaining
because it's not her to, it's so dumb. And then she'll post on like Sunday,
like, hey everybody. What's your favorite ice cream flavor?
I just want Twitter to go. Fuck you. How about that?
My favorite flavors each yet it's Anna draw 50 that's my favorite flavor.
The whole thing is fucking, the whole thing is ridiculous.
Like you can stack the rocks on top of a piss test.
That guy come out green like less than like a Ninja clerical like radiator
fluid. The fuck is lime green like the Ferrari man.
When we were kids there was no 50 year old action heroes.
They didn't look like that. No.
How the fuck do you look like that's just alone these days.
I do a horrible special own impression like what is he doing now?
He's doing something that isn't even rewriting fucking a some TVs like rocky
nine or some shit and he's doing a TV show with like Dolph Lundgren.
They're doing a TV show yet. Appreciate the hustle man. Who was he 70 something?
He's a thousand years old and still swinging for the bleachers.
He doesn't give a fuck in a town. Gigantic Mozo from Baba.
So proud to announce there's incredible new show called the Endo Nijah show.
It's going to be there.
Does that working with my own hard punch in front of fans. [inaudible]
his, his Instagram is dolphin fans.
Doff underscore fans still working on a new TV series together and we can't
wait. Who said that? I can definitely fill a hard path for your boy hair.
Hard patch and stars are collaborating again, dude.
They just don't give it up to it. I will say this though. Savannah,
that mother fucker with the, like the Rockies,
even the newer ones I created and stuff. He's,
he's doing well or did you see the escape with him and Arnold?
They're both like a hundred years old. See that all. It's fucking good.
They've got beards. It's fucking good, man. It's a good movie dude.
They don't miss when they make movies now this, that's going to be terrible,
but their movies, is that going to be terrible? Maybe
[inaudible] the extracts.
You still jacked looking at me. Look at his forearms. Hey,
remember when he got those forums? Oh Dude. Have you seen his answer?
He's shredded man. Let me see some recent pieces. Fucking jacked.
I wish I could go to his ass. Shot his Instagram. Did you see,
did you see when he got caught in Australia though? Am Son? Oh,
his daughter is a smoke show. She's up age to be cool.
A uh,
did jack do weird like drawing lines on it?
Like someone accidentally threw the screenshot thing on it and didn't take it
off before the post that, oh, well he's he,
he's 90 so he didn't know bro.
He probably posted himself and can't see what he wrote on it.
He probably signed it that he was autographing his own fucking Instagram.
Take a look at. This is a good dude.
You want me to see some photos of him where he's like, Oh hey,
go to the one where he's walking an alligator at his daughter's birthday party.
There it is. Far Right. It's awkward. It's, he's stiff.
You know how you said I was stiff? He is so stiff.
I'm going to say please like physically stiff.
I'll go for a walk, but then again,
I have my friend here. He's got a porcupine in his house,
if you know what I mean. Oh yeah.
He's a little awkward,
but you got to think all those years of lifting weights and he broke his neck
when he was filming the expenditure, the
Bulls. He's got bolts and shit in his neck. He ever see it, bro.
He's got his neck fused like several of his disc blew out filming the expendable
fucking right. They take, cause you're 90 jumping out of planes and shit.
Somebody threw him into a wall. He was doing his own stunts.
I blow my asshole out. Some of them I in a little wall. Fuck.
But there's never been a guy as old as him that literally pulls off doing uh,
like when he smashes somebody in a movie, you're not going no way.
It's not like when Bob Barker beat up Adam Sandler and happy gill. No,
I believe in that price is wrong bitch. It's not like that.
It's like a guy fucking a guy up like you buy it. Yeah, you're right.
He's still jacked. Like he'll still fuck people up. [inaudible]
now he's a legend man. I like, he's the fucking light.
He's just doing the damn thing. How long can he do it though? Could,
will you buy it when he's 90. Oh, he's still going to be able to fuck people up.
[inaudible] towards doing the damn thing. That's true. However,
he owes me fucking seven 99 for renting the mule was a piece of shit.
He's 94 directing, starring his own movie is not good. It's tough.
It's just boring. It's him driving down the highway. That's it. That's it.
Wasn't he supposed to be a drug meal in that movies and that was the best part
is though. He gets to the cartel and then the, hey, just have these smoke shows.
Fuck his brains out. Fuck his brain. And he's like 90 yeah. That's pretty cool.
Yeah. He's like, yeah, well yeah, he wrote and directed it.
Really important that I fuck dude, he's 90 at least, right?
I think he's 92 right? He's killing it. He's still bangs out. Well,
he wrote it in the script. You got divorced. I want freedom.
He has a bunch of kids, man. You got a bunch of kids.
I've had one of my sons on Scott. No, nice guy. Looks like them too.
It looks like he does look like him. Yeah, you gotta imagine that.
Plenty's where's your dad? Not around a lot.
Probably not teach how to play catch and shit.
Starting fucking whatever the movies he's doing. Yeah, that's a problem.
Yeah. I mean, when you're doing movies too,
you're off for months and months and months at a time, and I don't know.
This is just me to calculate in my head. I know how busy I am.
But then you look at the rock schedule. Yeah. Dude, why did he go home? Well,
it probably brings his family with him. Does he? I mean,
I would imagine you see, I don't know. I don't know. I don't know either.
How do you not? I mean, you know the rock. Yeah.
You're the rock. I couldn't do it. I would need my kids to be [inaudible].
I would die if I'm on the road longer than four days. I die. It's I,
I don't do well. When I did the only two movies that I've ever done,
the Kevin James Movies, the here comes the boom. I brought my family with me.
I'm like, I'm not doing this. How long was it? Two weeks. Three weeks,
two. I'm like, that can't do it, man. Too Long. Yeah. That's my third whiskey,
by the way. Yeah. It's just the fucking,
that's the sadness and the solidness dude. Be By yourself.
Face timing your family. And it's like, oh well my son goes, Daddy,
where are you? I'm trying to describe it. He's like, class you. Yeah.
Those little voices. I miss you so much. Oh Man. Oh. Can't do it.
I gotta get back. That's why I only do weekends when I go on the road.
I do weekends. Yeah, you're at a level now where it's perfect man. That that's,
that's Hashtag goals is kid Hashtag Inspo is when uh,
you can do like one or two huge shows a month.
So you're not missing stuff at home. I was thinking about this. Oh, go ahead.
No, go ahead. Go ahead. You were thinking about this. Um,
when my son starts playing sports, I don't want to miss a game. Right.
While I'm on the road for Thursdays, I'm up to figure it out.
Hopefully by the time he starts doing that,
I'm on a level where I don't have to do so many shows every week. You know?
I don't know. I'm trying to figure it out. I,
I couldn't sleep the other night thinking about it.
You know there's another thing too when you think about it,
like when do you retire? Like as a con would be. Yeah.
Do you want to be George Carlin to be dying a hotel room somewhere?
You know better than me, Joe, you told me brother. I don't know.
I'm thinking about it cause I'm older than you too.
You know I'm going to be 52 in August but you never been better.
I know that's the problem I experienced is the name of the game never been
better. It's also, it's experience but it's also focus,
discipline, enthusiasm, all those things haven't weaned and,
but you're also not out of touch. Like you ever see some old comedians.
I won't say names, but I seem to stamp like, oh bro,
you open up fucking Twitter.
You're talking about fucking on Jersey shore.
That show hasn't been relevant in seven years. Dumb ass.
But he or they're just not current, you know, they have no idea. I think look,
stand up. Comedy is a constant pursuit.
You take like I took a couple days off from this weekend, right?
I did this weekend was Chapelle.
I took Sunday and Monday off and then Tuesday I got to get back on the horse
again and you've got to really get back on the horse.
You got to go over the nodes, you can't have acid.
You've got to really prepare and you've been doing it for how long? Forever.
Forever. You gotta come out guns, blaze. And every time and then you know,
obviously I'm gearing up for this weekend.
I got a sold out show at an arena and Portland on Friday night.
You're at her freeness us.
We're basketball teams play
just talking shit. It's so cool. He is. He ain't going with you. Yeah, this one.
Yeah. And Allie, Allie Makowski. She's Great Love Alec. Love Ellen.
She's a lot of water.
She's like 22 I love watching her get better and she's so smart.
She's a beast man. Hard works hard. She works hard.
She was with me last night at the Improv. She's with me tonight. Ty's house.
She grinds kids always grind and dude, I had a,
or Derek posting a as my feature and uh, he's been with me for a while.
He's a comedy store. He's great.
He's from Memphis and we did shows in Nashville and his parents came to the
show, Hey, his dad is white as fuck. So I was a little confused.
Those mom was super dark, that's whatever. But I was just like, wow,
how's this happen?
I felt like a proud dad telling them how good he's doing.
I started tearing up like this guy, man. The Dad was like, all right man,
be cool. He's got real potential. I mean, I'm talking killer Joe. There's,
there's guys,
friends of ours that are comedians who brought Derek on the road and he crushed
show hard. He, they don't bring him in anymore. You're coming with me, bro.
That's how I met her. You come in with me. That's hilarious.
He's been doing comedy like three years. I think he's been doing a six or seven.
I didn't really, but I mean, you know,
no small amount of time for you to be scared of him. Yeah, he's a monster man.
Well, you know, that's nice, but it's, we need more, you know, I'm,
I'm a big encourager of young comedians. We need more.
We need as many as we can. You know, it was really funny. Oh,
I had a work with me at the Improv the other night is Jimmy o Yang.
He's amazing. Hilaire oh, I worked with them at the Ja comedy store, rather.
I saw him at the Improv and then I had them come and do a set. Yeah,
I brought him up. I went after him at the Improv and I was like,
he destroyed all seven people. Funny Dude. Yeah. He, he's amazing.
He's a great two and funny offstage. Just a fun dude. It was so funny.
Meeting with, we were at the Improv and, uh,
we're chilling the back-talking and this like random Asian dude comes up and
goes, are you Chinese? And he goes, no, I'm actually not.
And he goes like through this whole Asian thing and the guy that,
he was fucking hate that man. He was Asian people too.
It was so funny. What nationality is Jimmy? I think he's Korean.
I think Jimmy don't kill me. Fuck. I just think he's Korean. Fuck this up.
I hope not.
I got a bunch of Asian people that work for me and I messed it up all the time.
Do you think Asian people do that with white people? Like are you Portuguese?
I don't think so. It's pretty obvious. Pretty obvious. Oh, you Polish you Paul.
Are you Swedish? What are you never go? Oh, you're white. Born in Hong Kong.
According to Wikipedia. It's tough, dude. It's tough.
I've got a Filipino that works for me and I got a Korean.
Have you ever watched those fucking protests on TV?
Where at [inaudible] they been going now and they're making changes,
aren't they? It's been gone forever. It hasn't gone for a hot second. People.
I've been avoiding the news with the mass shootings. I got an Assu.
Nothing gets me into a depression like mass shootings. Now it's Obama bomber,
man. It's a bummer. And it's like, you know, I had Bernie Sanders on yesterday.
That's what scares me even more. We had him on. You go burning.
What are you gonna do with this? No answers. No one has an answer.
No one smart as fuck.
Banning assault rifles and all the NRA people are like, good luck with that.
See, but here's my thing. I know you've got a big, hey,
you gotta take her away from me. Oh my God.
We're looking at a photo of Hong Kong right now and it is the most insane crowd
of people that are filling the street. It's like a sand of beach sand of people.
It's like the women's march times a million on sterile.
That women's march was weak as fuck. No, this is serious shit.
Is he hats there now they're ready to kill.
So what is the problem?
There was anti extradition bill that people are, oh, because yeah,
that extradite people to China to get prosecuted. Correct. Is that what it is?
And they don't want that shit. Anti X. Okay. Okay. Um,
process series of ongoing demonstrations in China, in Hong Kong,
rather against the fugitive offenders and mutual legal
assistance in criminal matters legislation amendment bill proposed by the
government of Hong Kong.
This legislation was proposed by the security bureau in 2019 in response to a
murder that occurred in Taiwan the previous year,
which the suspect had fled to Hong Kong as a special administrative region.
Hong Kong is jurisdictionally distinct from mainland China and maintains a
separate governing and legal system under the one country,
two systems principle.
The regional government was unable to transfer the fugitive Taiwanese
authorities citing a lack of formal extradition arrangements between the two
jurisdictions. Say Hong Kong, pick your battles. Yeah. If enacted,
the bill would allow local authorities to detain and extradite people who are
wanted in countries or territories that Hong Kong does not have extradition
agreements with, including mainland China. Well,
the problem is that Hong Kong until a certain, yeah,
well Hong Kong was controlled by Britain, right.
Until a certain amount of time, and then they gave it back to China.
And the people that live there are very unhappy with this shift from a think it
was Great Britain. Not they're pissed. Yeah. Talk about.
And then yet the dedication is very, it's so rigid. I mean,
there's so authoritarian. Scary. You're lucky counseling here.
You'd have a three hour podcasts either. Did you say Hong Kong and China?
Let me break it down for you. Um, here's my thing. Back to the,
the mass shootings and like gun control with the semiautomatic weapons.
If they said, hey man, if we get rid of semiautomatic weapons,
there won't be any more mass shootings like this. Don't you think? In general,
most people are like, yeah, cool. Take them in. Are they that fun? No.
Are they that cool to shoot? People would not do that. There's that.
Why do you need them? Doesn't it doesn't matter whether you need them.
A stupid Joe. Listen to this stupid. It's a real problem man.
The kids are dying left and right. Okay, but you're looking at it the wrong way.
You got to look for an answer. Yes. In terms of the way they are looking at it,
they're not going to say, okay,
you take them because their ideas that government eventually wants all your guns
and they're going to start with assault rep weapons and then work their way to
all weapons. What if they just stopped at a, sorry,
you're looking at worst case scenario.
What if it is just assault because of the mass shootings?
Because they don't think that they should be able to do that.
They think that the government does not have the ability to take away your guns,
but we haven't Snobelen. The problem is crazy people shooting people.
The problem is noise automatically. The problem guns shooting people, right.
It's interesting.
You're going to go after those people that have the guns that have never done
anything. Well, hey, you're going to say, well,
the Second Amendment protects my right to keep and bear arms amendment's written
in the 17 hundreds that hasn't changed. True. The thing is though is if you can,
hey, we have a problem. If we can get rid of these for now.
What I'm saying is that most Americans would be like, yeah, you're right man.
We don't need them. That bed. No chance. That's mind blowing. To me it is,
but people went, hey, Brendan,
Ferrari's are killing people left and fucking right, dude,
you gotta get off the road with this thing.
So many people are dying like get rid of the fucking fraud. Yeah,
but that's a simplistic perception of what's actually going on.
No one's going to think about it that way. They're gonna think,
I mean the people that don't have guns are going to think about it that way that
the people that are second amendment enthusiastic are going to say this is a
slippery slope and I don't give them any ground.
Like Joe Biden has been saying we're going to take your assault weapons.
This is one of the things that Joe Biden has said publicly and this is one of
the reasons why the people that are pro second amendment are never gonna vote
for him. They think that if you give in in any way,
shape or form to take my free slope and they're going to take away pistols.
I mean California's already reduced the size of the magazines,
but that actually I think that was voted back like I think that was ruled to be
unconstitutional. They had like limited magazines.
Like you only have a magazine like six rounds or 10 rounds or something like,
no, it was 10 I think they try to make it lower,
but that that has been reversed. I'm pretty sure.
Here's my thing with the mental health or, and he goes, well,
America has a mental health problem.
There's a mental health problem all around the world.
We just have a gun problem. That's not true. The mental is just here.
The mental health problem in United States is extremely exacerbated by the use
of psych drugs. There's way, way, way more drug prompts to brother.
They don't have nearly as many prescribed drugs in Europe as they do.
Are you sure? Yes. SSRI talked to Bernie saying, oh, well,
I know I do not. As I've talked to psychologists. Yeah,
you've probably done your research.
It's this pharmaceutical lobby in this country. Look,
obviously not everybody on psych drugs is that murdering people.
The problem is many, many, many layers, right? There's people that are abused.
There's people that grow up with a lot of violence.
There's people that grow up and they, you know, they're psychotic. They,
they have psych drugs. The psych drugs are disassociated.
Some people just be bad apples though.
Like does it always have to be a mental illness?
Like all these shooters just happen to have mental illness? All of them.
Well someone just don't suck at life. Maybe some suck at life,
but almost all of them. I mean in the high 90% are on psych medication.
Yes,
and as coming from someone who's who was murdered by his wife when she was on an
SSRI and on cocaine, like people when they're on those drugs, it's,
it's a varying reaction and suicidal thoughts are very common as well as
homicidal thoughts. Very common. The and also the,
the feeling that things aren't real.
The people that I've talked to that were on SSRI as they got off of them,
one of the things that they all say is that nothing seemed real.
That's kind of what you did in every game. Like a simulation. Yes.
Everything is blank and those kids, yeah, everything felt flat.
I think that's a big problem for sure.
A crazy person with a semiautomatic weapon is a real problem and you would want
to take a semiautomatic weapon away from a crazy person, the other PR.
But the problem is if there's a guy like you who has a semiautomatic weapon and
you have a ranch somewhere and he just like shooting coyotes and fucking fucking
metal targets that are out in the distance and you don't harm anybody and you're
a good person, you are technically protected by the second amendment.
Why should you? But okay, but then what about your pistol?
Should you take your pistol? What about your shotgun?
What if you get a shotgun and you fucking keep reloading it automatic again to
the, with shotgun, they're not going to kill as many people.
Depends on whether or not the people are armed.
If the people are not armed and running around a mall,
you can kill a lot of fucking people with a shotgun. The automatic yes, maybe.
Yeah, maybe. I mean, here's what the scary thing me,
you're one of the smartest people I know. Bernie Sanders is smart motherfucker.
This, he lives in this world. When you said, what are we going to do? His aunts,
I was like, that was as good as mine. It's the truth. You're right, dude.
You're right. There's no one that scared me.
It's a good thing to be scared because there's no one out there has a shining
light like one answer you like. That's it. The smartest minds in the world,
and then I'm listening. I'm like, well, I've thought of that.
That's not going to work for me, dude.
The Joe Biden answers that dumb ass answer. We're going to take away your guns.
You're going to have a civil war. Guns. You can't,
you can't take away the St take away assault guns and assault rifles.
You're not going to do that. They're not going to give them the constitutional.
They do give Joe, let's say they do do it. There's too many out already, right?
There's too many on the market.
So let's say you bought 100 million guns in this case.
How many people that there's 300,000 people in this 300 million.
There's 100 million more guns than there are people. Okay. So you're,
so if you stop the manufacturer of automatic guns right now,
there's still 100,000 more than people out there and then you'd have to go get
them, but you'd have to go door to door and search. We can't do that. You can't,
that's what everyone's thinking will happen.
It's not realistic like the porridge or some shit.
How else are you going to get those guns from this? Clearly not.
The answer is that that's never going to happen. Now it's something, you know,
no one's going to give you those guns. So that's not the answer.
I don't know what the answer is. I don't either.
But the crazy thing is if you look at the mass shootings across the world,
the most and other countries see like two or three.
I know for us it's over 300 already this year,
yet I think it's two 70 something in a mass shooting is three or more. Yeah. Um,
the other thing to me that's interesting is I used to always think it was kids
who on you know are in their basement and on bread at their,
these losers and they have nothing to live for. Probably true.
Some of them sub most nine out of 10. But then you got homeboy like a over in a,
where was it, Ohio who had these chicks are coming out.
He's banging a few girls had a bunch of girls that are like, man, we saw signs.
He was always talking about mass shootings. Like you have a bracing something.
He had a rape list in high school. Yeah, they all fed. He's fucked up.
They all thought he was really fucked up.
But he was also Elizabeth Warren supporter who wrote a post about the need for
gun control after different mass shootings.
I mean he was a real left wing guy and this is something that the media is
ignoring because it doesn't fit the narrative because the narrative is they're
all white male right wing. And he was left wing when he was laughing. Like yeah,
he's a leftist. I mean, he, he wrote leftist, he,
him as his pronouns on his page. Wow. Yeah. I mean he was,
but that has nothing to do with him. He's a psychopath there.
They're saying the kid
that they caught and got in, I don't want to talk about them as students.
Bums me out when did, after this we'll move on something else. But, um,
they're saying the kid that caught in a El Paso who,
the one who did end up dying when she did die, but, um, he was saying that,
uh, it shows no remorse. He's like, fuck yeah, I did it man. And like,
are you kidding me dude? You killed kids. And he's like, you're damn right.
Shot a baby. How crazy is that? Oh,
and he's going to get a cushy fucking, you know, Rome. He's living better than,
than, you know,
most of these fucking immigrants that come here and get detained. It's insane,
man.
They should definitely kill them and they should definitely should torture them
in. Ah, just, just, just, ah, just a quick, it's, it's not fair, man,
but having them suffer doesn't help anybody. It really doesn't.
But having them around doesn't help anybody either. No,
you're not going to reform that. Here's the, here's the good thing though.
In his manifesto, he went, hopefully someone gets them in,
shoots me so I don't have to go through the legal system. That's way worse.
It'd be way better. Die Real quick. So at least he doesn't want this.
That's a good thing. Why is it all white dudes
that weirdness? You know Charlotte crazy. Charlemagne actually put that,
that it was all these white guys that white guys are the biggest threat in terms
of terrorism in America, and Instagram took his posts. How crazy is that?
They're more of a threat than isis,
but he had rows of all these different white guys who committed mass murders and
as a white guy, I'm like, yeah, yeah, me too. I went, go shit. Charlemagne.
Yeah, you right. But they took his post down. Well, how crazy is that?
Then they put it back up. They put it down right? They did.
Sherman has some power, man. Well, he made his case and he was correct.
He had literal photographs of all the different people that were white that have
committed mass murder. Just looked like shit named the last time.
The last time there was a black guy that committed a mass murder was those
fucking guys in d c they were shooting people out of their car.
I was talking about this DC sniper. It was a son and a father. Yeah.
It was a guy in a younger guy where the younger guy was his son. He,
that's a serial killer though. Yeah. Yeah.
Not so much a mass cause really wasn't at a time one. Yeah,
he wasn't killing three.
But that was scary because people were just at like gas stations getting
Mercked. Well, you know what, this fucking sniper in his van. Well, no,
he had a car and he had a snipers nest. Like he was shooting out of the trunk.
Oh, that's right. He had a hole in the trunk.
We put the barrel out of the trunk. I mean, scary dude. I mean,
you would just see people in the distance and just unload. Dude.
Have you seen the move on? Have you seen the documentary? Uh, um, I,
it's like terrorist John Isis. John. It's a documentary on HBO. No,
I heard that's crazy. Jihadi John Gotti. John. Yeah,
I heard it's crazy fucking memory. Yeah, it's crazy. It, oh,
it's fucking good dude. It's crazy. This was, uh,
like a normal dude grew up in England.
He was a refugee right from I think Syria or something like that.
Somewhere over in the Middle East comes England, played football, soccer,
football as they call it, grew up normal. Had friends,
was just a normal dude and then just went freaking happen to him.
They had these girls that went over from England too and they joined isis and
they're trying to get out and now the camp, cause they got over.
Then the homeys are run a train on yet 1:00 PM every day.
That's the way it goes. You fucking moron.
And you gotta dress like job of the hut. Yeah. Dressed like a Ninja.
[inaudible] thought it was, you have to pay.
You got to be pretty stupid. The fuck were you thinking, you know,
dressed like a Ninja and the homies gonna run a train on everyday.
What'd you think you would do with front front and center with automatic rifle
firing at Americans? You Morons.
I wonder what they thought of when they thought they were fighting for good.
Imagine if that's your daughter. Your daughter goes and joins isis like,
oh see I was thinking about this, the Manson murders, why I'm so into it.
I have no idea you got problems. But the Manson murders,
those girls were like 17 and 19 imagine when you're 17 well they were also
homeless. So you're dealing with people that are probably crazy. Crazy.
And then this was, that was their family, right?
This was like the first time they'd ever had like real family and they didn't
know the murder,
what the exactly they were going to do till they got to the house.
Then they're like, all right. I guess one girl dips out, the other two are like,
all right, let's do this. It was once upon a time in Hollywood,
their depiction of it twist. You saw it movie loved it.
I cannot get enough of the 60s I want to 68 Porsche right in that movie.
Like amazing. Yeah. I mean, Brad Pitt was great in that movie.
Leonardo DiCaprio and Oscar. They were both amazing. How about,
how about the way they depicted a Bruce Lee?
That was fucked up was it, was it, was it not? I don't know.
Like I,
and I'm sure Bruce Lee's Dodger's gonna jump all over it for the stuff I've
heard. Bruce Lee was a philosopher. W was he a fighter?
Was He really that much of a bad-ass? I don't know. Like I've heard,
I've heard he is, I've heard from people like, no,
and he's never been really a lot of fights. I've heard, I've heard both.
So what I thought was great is they put like Quentin Tarantino put his
perspective on it where it's like,
I've heard that narrative and I loved it because I've let,
I've seen it both ways. I've heard where he was in that much of a bad-ass,
like he doesn't have a crazy record. Yeah. But there wasn't just that. It was,
he was a dummy in the movie and the problem was in real life there's no evidence
that he was ever at like an egomaniac dummy.
He was very interesting guy and very insightful. And I do and I believe,
and he was like a philosopher and he's brilliant.
But when it comes to the actual toughness, we don't, we don't know.
We don't, we don't know for sure. But that's one. Yeah.
You've heard that narrative before, right? What narrative that like,
like he's not an actual tough guy. Well, what I had heard was that it,
at the time, he was incredibly innovative in terms of martial arts,
but he didn't really fight and he had like a sparring match wants at a
tournament and he had some street fights, but he didn't, you know,
he wasn't like John Jones and that.
But then I've also heard that he was this bad-ass and fought other dudes from
Dojo Joe's and he's amazing. Yeah. I'm somewhere in the middle. I went and I,
but he's a big base of all. So what was not the problem though?
The problem is they made him look like a buffoon and there's no evidence I need
a little problem with, it's a movie everyone's crying about.
It's going to turn about a real person who was a real legacy and about to come
on Joe. It's a fucking Quintin Tarantino movie. And the way that they,
I don't want to give it spoil the ending, but the ending too. That's not real.
Well that's true. Then they had a totally different ending,
like you're living to make believed everything. No one's real.
In that step forward, like obviously the, the ranch is real where they went,
Charles Manson, who is barely in it, the Manson family, but everyone,
everyone's kind of dumb.
Like even even Leonardo DiCaprio whose character is a bit of a kidding.
He's a bit of a dumb ass. Yeah. But that real guy might've been a dumb ass.
I mean we don't know. But we do know that about Pursley either. Yeah.
But there's a lot of evidence that Bruce Lee was this brilliant,
insightful guy and in that movie they made him a caricature of that.
And you have a problem with that? I did. I stood up. I didn't lie flat.
I don't have a problem with it because it's nice. It was so good.
Cause I thought, I thought Bruce, he's going to beat the fuck out of Brad Pitt.
And then when you see that when I went,
that twist is hilarious cause y'all don't expect it. And I,
I think of Bruce Lee as a bad ass, which he is.
Whether he's been in a million fights or not.
The way what he's done for martial arts is his own president.
It's amazing what he did. So take that twist for me in the mood.
That's what I want from the family's reaction. Oh my God,
the sisters are may his daughter's pissed. She'd be pissed if that was my dad.
Like fuck you. And that movie is so big. Like fuck you guys.
Cause when's the last time Bruce Lee got brought up besides Jesse at root to
fight selling a Bruce Lee t-shirt?
When's the last time you got brought the fuck up?
The dude who played brucey was not shredded enough. Yeah,
he should've been more shredded. Conch round.
See I like the twist because eight, it's not real. B,
you thought Bruce Suzanne beat the fuck out of back then. I did for sure.
I was like, oh, he's about to get fucked up. I knew the way he don't.
Bruce Lee doing that, jumping, flying kick, his signature kick.
That's probably how it towed. Right?
Talking about with the guy who's been in fights like, get the fuck Outta here,
Bruce Lee's philosophy in real fights though,
was that keeping things simple like leg kicks and quick punches.
You're living rowdy Joe. You're living in the legs here. Bruce Lee,
which is probably true, but in a Quintin Tarantino movie.
That was fucking great, man. I thought that movie's brilliant.
Movie was brilliant.
I did not like the Bruce Lee things because I thought it was,
it wasn't necessary. It was there. They made him look like a Dork,
but everyone sucks his dick. So to mix it up,
it's fantastic. Like Bruce Lee, everyone, you know, he's the best.
And I agree he's the best.
So it's a movie that's supposed to be about a real guy that has a real legacy
and they made him look like a buffoon. It's the Dan V's though. I know,
but they, they, you know, you're making the guy look like a fucking idiot. Yeah.
But anyone who wasn't really an idiot, it wasn't anybody at all. Not at all.
He's a brilliant philosopher.
And what he did for martial arts is that is amazing. That's what's great.
That's what's great. Cause we know he has, he's great.
And you assume he's going to beat up Brad Pitt, right?
You're a weird fucking guy. I Dunno. Why he like, I think that's good.
I like the twist. Like if you were to beat Brad Pitt up, I went. All right.
Well all right. Yeah, moving on. I didn't think that was gonna happen.
I thought Brad Pitt was gonna fuck him up. I didn't prep it. Knew how to fight.
Yeah.
Who's that bigger guy and he knew how to fight and the reality is a bigger guy
who knows how to fight.
Who really knows that if I is gonna fuck up 130 pound shines. Right.
You're thinking about it too much.
Did you think about things [inaudible] though? Yeah, you do. You're like, oh,
I loved it. The twist. I love the twist. His family is furious. Right?
You got anything on that? Is his daughter's pissed? She did a video.
I was looking into, uh, just people talking about what really happened, I guess.
Or this might come from a story from some, oh,
there was a real interaction between the two styles.
I'm trying to figure out how to pick this up. It's already four 30. Is it?
Fuck out of here. Um, can I have everybody? Wait? What's going on? K,
where's your, where's your comedy tonight? Everybody?
I'm in Portland next week with a Derek Postin Chappelle, Lacey, Portland,
helium. Thursday, Friday. Saturday is two monsters.
Did a good show and then still go back. Flip. Yes. He's a male cheerleader.
Easy cheese. Wider than you and me. Yeah. He's so powerful.
He's like Greenbay through this girl up. The girl weighed like a hundred pounds,
threw her up in the air card, her on one hand and she standing on his hand.
I'm like, God damn that dude strong. However,
we played basketball at my house and he couldn't get through a game of 21 love
Chappelle though. Why not? Not In shape for basketball, bro. Oh,
we mean the exhausted started. You do that too. Yeah, I know.
That's what he say. He say he loves it. Yeah. Uh, but so I'm in, uh, Portland,
uh, next week, Thursday, Friday, Saturday, Portland, helium.
Then after I'm in Houston, then Denver September. Get your tickets.
[inaudible] DOT com. Yes, sir. I love you man. Love you too, brother. Alright,
bye everybody. See Ya.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].